hello everyone welcome to the November
2022 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll so I don't know what's going on
in your info sphere these days but in
the corners where I hang out people are
kind of obsessed with the idea of what's
happening to Twitter with Elon Musk
buying it I'm very active on Twitter
pretty active you know a couple of
tweets a day maybe on average not even
every day do I do it I know there's some
people who do dozens or hundreds a day
I'm not in that super level but it's uh
valuable to me Twitter it's valuable to
a lot of people
um who are journalists and writers
especially I've met friends on Twitter
it's an important thing it's also a bit
of a mess right it's completely
unmoderated I don't it's not completely
a moderate that's not true but it's
largely unmoderated I'm not thinking
about hate speech and things like that
I'm thinking about just dumb goofy
comments that people leave anyone can
come in to your Twitter thread and say
something which doesn't always lead to
the best conversations so I've always
thought of Twitter as extremely useful
but useful not for debating deep issues
but for pointing out interesting things
making a rye comment or a joke having
some fun
um sharing pointers to the rest of the
world is the most important thing that
Twitter does and people complain that
it's not a better
discussion forum and it was just never
meant for that in my mind but anyway
with Elon buying it people are worried
that it's going to change somehow and I
honestly don't know whether it will or
not I think it certainly will change
somehow I don't know whether it will be
dramatic or whether we will you know a
year from now left that we were all
worried about it but it just reminds me
that the there's a certain ephemerality
to these kinds of things there's a lot
of people who are saying well I'm
leaving Twitter I'm going to Mastodon or
something like that and it could very
well happen there's nothing keeping
everyone using Twitter all the time
there's certainly been other uh social
media sites or other things on the
internet that people have left I've
basically left Facebook years ago and I
didn't minded that at all you know
there's some sadness because I don't get
to see pictures of my friends or
um reminders of their birthdays and so
forth but you move on and you find other
things so Twitter could die and again
regardless of your feelings about
whether Elon will bring that about it's
a reminder that these things that become
very important don't last forever and
that in turn is a reminder of the fact
that we are living in a time in history
where we're really nowhere near
equilibrium right things are changing
very very rapidly and it's that makes it
very very hard to predict the future
because it's always hard but especially
hard because today is different than
yesterday and it's very hard to
extrapolate or think that anything about
the current state is typical or
permanent or anything like that and uh
it's hard to wrap our minds around that
or the human brain is just not quite
built for coping with changes on such a
grand scale on such a rapid time scale
and thinking about what they will mean
for time scales beyond our actual human
lives so I wanted to point to that and I
remembered that there was a question in
today's AMA that actually got to this so
I'm going to do something I don't
usually do which is to ask the question
here in the intro and then we'll move on
but Johann Falk says I can't get rid of
the feeling that we're living in a time
when a lot is at stake like what we do
now has huge implications for the future
of humanity I'm thinking of global
warming AI increasing weak against them
mentality China becoming the next new
superpower things like that this gives
me some anxiety but also makes me want
to do things that help us move in the
right direction whatever that is so
number one do you think that we're at
some kind of crucial point in history
number two do you think that most people
throughout history have felt that
they're at some kind of crucial point
and number three do you have any
thoughts on how such a feeling can be
harnessed into something good instead of
mostly feeling despair
well on the third one the feeling good
I'm not so sure uh that I have any good
thoughts I think that it can different
people will react differently to this
feeling that things are at a crisis
point or at an inflection point or
something like that some people will be
energized by that leap Into The Fray and
try to make things better some people
will be overwhelmed by it and Retreat
and try to find a safe place and I can't
criticize either either way I think
that's a difficult question that
individuals are going to approach
differently I do have opinions about the
first two versions of the question do I
think that we're at some kind of crucial
point in history I would say yes and no
well actually let me group that together
with the second one which is do you
think that most people throughout
history have felt that they're at some
kind of crucial point you know maybe
they have but I would argue that there
is something different about the present
time uh for two reasons one is because
like I just said things are changing
rapidly you know think about just the
recent podcast with will mccaskill or
Brad Delong really really impressing
upon us the rapidity of rates of change
and we've had plenty of podcasts in the
past few years that make this point in
one way or the other but the other point
is that we're more powerful than we used
to be you know the physical world is
full of tremendously large and
potentially destructive or constructive
energies and technology has given us the
ability to harness some of those
energies in ways that we haven't before
um part of this is as simple as we're
much more connected uh if you're on
Twitter it's much easier to know what is
going on in Iran uh at an up-to-date
minute by minute basis than it would
have been back in the day just a few
decades ago right but another part of it
is that we can do tremendous damage to
the planet whether it's nuclear war or
climate change or potential biological
hazards one way or another right whether
or not uh you are of the belief that the
covid-19 virus had something to do with
testing in a lab when it originated
there's no question that something like
that could happen that human beings
could engineer something that could be
way more devastating than covid-19 has
been so I think we have a lot more
leverage now over the whole globe than
we ever used to and so I think we are
justified in thinking of our current
point in time as a crucial point now
having said that it might seem much less
crucial than a point 100 years from now
seems once we get to 100 years from now
because presumably our ability to affect
the world is just going to go up but
certainly compared to what was going on
500 years ago you can easily imagine
human beings changing our future history
in a dramatic way now compared to 500
years ago or 5 000 years ago or whatever
so I do think it's right to take this
seriously you know in a very very
localized sense for those of you here in
the U.S you know that we're
um right next to our election day
midterm elections I I go on all the time
here about democracy and how democracy
is under threat and how people don't
really appreciate it
um and one of the ways it's under threat
is that there's a lot of people on the
ballot even though there's not a
presidential race there's a lot of races
for things like Secretary of State of
some individual State the person who is
in charge of counting the ballots and
sending the results forward to Congress
or to whatever so a lot of the mess that
we had two years ago was eventually
brought up short by good hearted
bureaucrats good-hearted people in
positions of responsibility saying no we
are not going to let this election
result be overturned if the election
results this week go a certain way that
might no longer be the case two years
from now and the United States is is one
of the longest operating continuously
operating democracies in the world right
now there's no reason why that has to
keep going right so that's just yet
another way in which things can change
very dramatically so I think it's
perfectly legit to think that we are in
a historically crucial time now what are
we going to do about it well I think
there's a bunch of things to do about it
none of them you know whenever you say
what are we going to do about it the
question is who's this we we're we're
talking about I mean like literally you
and me we're not going to do that much
you know I can come on my podcast and
complain about threats to democracy or
biological terrorism or whatever and the
world is not going to change that much
because of my thoughts on that being
spread throughout the various podcast
apps but collectively we could do a lot
you know the thing that is most
depressing to me about the the Democracy
side of things is that democracy isn't
that popular you know I mean this is
literally true in the sense that
political operators who are doing
polling for candidates are saying you
know what are the big themes that would
resonate with you this election season
and safeguarding democracy is always
near the bottom for both Democrats and
Republicans and it's in a more abstract
way if you ask people about you know
would it be better if we just had one
really good person in charge rather than
this messy having people vote and have
their say thing there's a lot of people
who would just rather have one competent
person in charge at deep down democracy
is not that popular and it's almost a
miracle it's lasted this long so what
can we do about that you know education
um you know we take a lot of things for
granted when I grew up you know
democracy was just a good thing we knew
that was a good thing and we didn't
really dig that deeply into it
um you know look I'm always I'm always
afraid when someone says what should we
do about it that I'm just going to say
we should do all the things I like doing
that's generally the way that people go
but one of the things I like doing is
being careful about ideas digging into
them very very carefully you know on
Twitter I pointed out that Free Speech
the phrase free speech is being used as
a cuddle
um on this side and that side and
whatever and what it does is it just
dumbs down the discourse free speech is
crucially important but it's also not
simple it's complicated and you can
listen to various podcasts I've done
Teresa Beijing is probably the most on
point here but we all agree when push
comes to shove that certain kind of
speech is should not just be spread all
over the place and certain kinds should
be unfettered and drawing the line is
very difficult and understanding the
philosophical justifications for there
being a line and for there being a value
to free speech it's all very difficult
and nuanced and so I've think we should
not take it for granted I think we
should talk about it and think about it
and decide why we think this is such a
big idea if we knew we had a better idea
why we thought the Free Speech was so
important which I do we do a better job
of understanding how to protect it in
ways that are compatible with other
values that we would also like to
protect there's no absolutism here
there's many values that we care about
and we want to balance them off against
each other and that's hard and requires
thinking so I don't know Johan if that's
a helpful answer or not but I think that
each of us individually can take the
responsibility to be a little bit less
simplistic be a little bit less glib you
know I'm always going back to the
podcast I did with t Wen who was a
really really that was a very
influential podcast for me where he
points out the the seductiveness of
Simplicity and Clarity and gamification
and how that leads into conspiracy
theories and things like that but even
if you're not in a cult or a conspiracy
theory everyone wants Simplicity they
want Clarity and the world doesn't
always provide it and values like free
speech versus other values is a
situation where it's not simple and you
have to embrace that and and honor that
that's but then again I'm just saying
that people should be more like me which
is sort of a cheap and easy thing to do
so uh anyway I'm not in charge no one is
putting me in charge of Twitter or
nuclear war or climate change or
anything like that but at least we can
keep the conversation going maybe make
everyone's thoughts about these issues a
little bit more clear and helpful and do
our little tiny part in that way with
that quasi crypto optimistic note let's
go
[Music]
thank you
the Cyber monk says I'm currently
reading volume one of the biggest ideas
in the universe good for you cyber monk
I hope everyone is out there reading the
book you know it's November so there's a
whole bunch of gift giving oriented
holidays coming up the biggest ideas in
the universe makes a great gift for
anyone in your family so anyway the
question continues that was my little
editorial comment I borrowed the ebook
from my local public library which is
how I get practically all the books I
read as a software engineer I easily
make enough money to buy them instead
assuming that would be financially
favorable to the author do I have an
obligation to do so more generally can
one be so well off that one has an
obligation to stop using certain public
goods or to provide additional support
above and beyond what is otherwise
expected of a good citizen so you know
as an author I often joke that what I
really care about is not people reading
my books but just people buying my books
that that's what helps but guess what it
is a joke I'm just kidding I hope that
comes through very clearly I think it is
completely fine with me if you or anyone
else reads the book at public libraries
I'm a huge fan of public libraries my
initial inspiration to fall in love with
science came from hanging out on my own
local public library so by doing that in
some way you're supporting I mean maybe
even better if you like turned it in
late so you could pay a little late fine
and in that way I give a little cash to
your local public library
I appreciate the inclination here that
you're sort of pointing to you know are
you doing the best good for the World by
getting an ebook from the local public
library
um and maybe arguably not uh you know
again I'm also someone who makes enough
money I have a job a full-time job I'm
pretty comfortable in that way I like
money I like making more money and I do
things to make more money and those
things incentivize me doing things that
make other people happy but I'm not you
know struggling near the poverty line or
anything like that so among all the
authors who you could support by buying
their books I should be low on the
priority list if you are someone I think
who uh is living comfortably enough that
you can
um in some sense afford to give a little
bit more of your income than is
absolutely necessary then I think that's
a good thing to do
um I don't think you're under the
obligation to not use the public library
but maybe the money you would have spent
on a book give to some charity or
something like that give to some worthy
cause you know we've talked about that
also on the podcast and I have uh I
think at the beginning of next month's
AMA I'll do a little update on uh the
state of we had a if you remember back
we had uh when Joshua green was on the
podcast he he promised to
um give a sort of matching donation kind
of thing to uh mindscape listeners who
donated to giving multiplier and that
actually worked out really really well
so we'll have some good news to share
with the community there uh so some but
something like that I'm not going to
judge people on whether or not they give
to the Charities that I think they
should be giving to uh I think that
we're all trying our best here if you
want to give to your local puppy shelter
that's perfectly also okay with me
Brandon wheeler says has anything
discovered by the James Webb Space
Telescope altered your Credence on
physics fundamentals so no and my
Credence is that is extremely unlikely
that anything discovered by the Jing's
web Space Telescope will alter Mike
readings on physics fundamentals that's
just not what the telescope was designed
to try to do you know when you look at
the universe in a new way you can always
be surprised and we frequently are
surprised but the kinds of things that
Webb is looking at whether it's early
Galaxy formation or searching for uh
evidence you know looking at atmospheres
of exoplanets or something like that
these none of these are going to change
physics fundamentals there's other kinds
of science that we're going to learn
about but that's okay just because
something is big and exciting doesn't
mean it's going to give us new
information about the fundamental laws
of physics
I'm going to group two questions
together uh one is by John B Wyman who
says do you think it is possible in
principle for the human brain to
discover The Theory of Everything I
think not because the brain is part of
the theory it's like the so-called
Paradox does the set of all sets contain
itself and then Tim giannitzos says do
you agree with Thomas [ __ ] that there
will never be a final or definitive
scientific account of nature he gives
the analogy that scientific theories are
like organisms and evolution there is
not a final organism that evolution is
driving toward he argues similarly that
there is not a terminal scientific
Paradigm but simply those which better
allow us to frame certain puzzles so
they're not the same question Tim is
asking do you think there is a
definitive final account uh Theory of
Everything if you want to put it that
way and John is asking do you think that
we could ever find it if it were there I
presume and so I do think that there is
a theory of everything because there's
the universe the the universe exists
there is something that the Universe
does and whatever that is uh there's a
description of that that would be the
theory of everything that's it you know
um I see Zero reason to doubt that I
think it'd be much much harder to
imagine sort of a metaphysical stance in
which you literally could not frame or
describe what the universe does with
perfect accuracy then one in which you
can we're just not there yet the fact
that we're not there yet is the least
surprising thing in the world the
surprising thing is how much progress
we've made toward it so I I absolutely
think that there is some final
definitive scientific account of nature
do I think that the human brain can
Discover it there maybe maybe not but I
would if I were forced to I would lean
toward probably
and I I don't find I get the worry that
you say you know the brain is the part
of the theory therefore we're trying to
describe it but that's a little bit off
the Mark here in terms of what we're
trying to do here because a Theory of
Everything Is Not or assigned Theory of
Everything is not supposed to be a
specific a complete and precise
specification of the world
it's supposed to be a complete
specification of the patterns the laws
that the world obeys so when I say f
equals m a force equals mass times
acceleration by Isaac Newton that is a
pattern that is obeyed by every planet
in the solar system and every star in
the galaxy Etc I don't need to
ReDiscover it or restate it every time
that's the great thing about the laws of
physics that's something I dwell upon at
Great length in the biggest ideas in the
universe the universality of these laws
so we would think that the human brain
obeys The Theory of Everything whatever
it is but that's no obstacle at all to
the human brain discovering it
Moshe fader says ligo's success in
detecting gravity waves was one of the
great physics achievements of our
lifetime so I understand that ligo will
now be followed by the Lisa project it
will employ three spacecraft orbiting
the Sun in an equilateral triangle
formulation formation with sides about
1.5 million miles long but I'm unclear
how Lisa will work surely it can't be by
the subtle length variation in laser
beams used by ligo can you explain the
method they'll be using
well I can explain it the level of a
theoretical physicist which is not very
deep you know there's an enormous amount
of Technology uh delicate highly
Advanced design development going on in
Lisa that uh you know this is a this is
a project that is yours in the future
not one that's going to happen anytime
soon but it will be a great way to look
for gravitational waves in a completely
different wavelength regime than ligo is
able to do but the short answer is it is
the same thing that ligo does because
you know ligo doesn't put down a meter
stick and then compare the length of
those meter sticks to the time it takes
light to travel or anything like that
what ligo is doing is firing lasers in
two different directions firing them in
One Direction and then another
perpendicular Direction and then tuning
it in such a way so that if there is no
gravitational wave passing by the two
returning laser beams interfere with
each other so this is a feature about
waves right where you can have one way
wave and another wave and then you
combine them and you get zero wave at
least a particular point in space
because where one wave is going up the
other wave is going down and vice versa
and what that means what that technique
means is that you don't even really need
to know the actual distance that the
light beam travels to a great Precision
because all you're looking for are
slight variations of that distance
because if the distance varies in One
Direction versus the other direction
that complete perfect cancellation of
the laser beams will go out of whack a
little bit and that's exactly what ligo
looks for and that's also basically
roughly speaking what Lisa will do you
have three spacecraft and you're
bouncing you know from one of them
you're bouncing lasers at one and the
other one and you're bouncing them back
and then you're trying to look for that
sort of inter interferometer
interferometry the interference of the
laser beams right so ligo stands for
um laser interferometer gravitational
wave Observatory Lisa stands for laser
interferometer space array I don't know
what the a stands for to be honest but
the point is they're both
interferometers using lasers that's why
they both have l i in them so it's
basically the same idea
Jacob zhongsma says would you be
surprised if a new physical Theory with
a similar impact is relativity or
quantum mechanics turns up
well that's a very good question
actually because it depends precisely on
what you mean by surprised in the long
term I would be not at all surprised
that they're that there are lurks out
there a better Theory than either
relativity or quantum mechanics that
will be similarly revolutionary but in
the short term if you know in in my
lifetime that's what I mean by the short
term I would be pretty surprised and the
reason is basically just that relativity
in quantum mechanics do really well
right there's no like lingering
anomalies or anything like that there
are puzzles there's the puzzle of the
origin of the universe there's the
puzzle of the cosmodial constant value
the hierarchy problem in quantum
mechanics uh and uh the electric weak
theory of particle physics and so forth
there's little puzzles and we need
better physics to account for them
there's no really strong evidence that
the better physics we need to account
for them is completely new and outside
the realm of Relativity and quantum
mechanics it might be but that's a
different situation than we had circa
1900 where we had things like the
structure of the atom and black body
radiation and so forth were just
strictly incompatible with uh what we
thought we knew about classical
mechanics and so that that led to a
revolution
Maxwell's equations and Newton's
equations for Gravity were strictly
incompatible and so relativity had to be
invented so usually the way that physics
or other Sciences actually make progress
is by trying to explain observational or
experimental anomalies and right now in
fundamental physics we don't know of
that many such anomalies I mean you can
say well there's dark matter sure but
it's so easy to explain Dark Matter
within the current Paradigm we don't
know what the right explanation is but
that's very different than saying we
don't have any way of explaining it so I
think that if there is a better Theory
it might take a while to figure it out
um but I'm willing to be surprised and
would certainly be very happy if I were
Sandro stooki says at the beginning of
the latest mindscape episode Barry lower
credits from eternity to here as one of
the two books that introduced
philosophers to the idea that
statistical mechanics is at the root of
all the special sciences causality and
the arrow of time when you wrote that
book did you hope to get philosophers
thinking about this connection did you
already think of yourself as a natural
philosopher back then
um so I I Barry did say that and you
know part of it maybe is him being
polite I don't want to know I don't want
to sort of speculate as to exactly how
influential my book was in the
philosophy Community Barry liked it um
he's one person but uh whether or not
that's true I did certainly have in mind
addressing questions that are of
interest to both physicists and
philosophers that was already true in
fact the arrow of time was basically
what got me into foundations of physics
and natural philosophy I liked
Philosophy from back when I was an
undergraduate in college but I liked
moral and political philosophy that's
what I actually studied the philosophy
of science stuff was too much about you
know Theory change and methodology which
was interesting but not anything I want
to do for a living when I started
thinking about inflation and the arrow
of time and Roger penrose's critiques of
inflation and things like that and I
wrote my paper with Jennifer Chen about
the arrow of time that's the first time
when I was really introduced to the
whole community of people working on
foundations of physics in a serious way
most of whom were philosophers but some
of whom are absolutely physicists so
um it's absolutely intentional that the
book that I wrote was one that addresses
issues that are of common interest to
physicists and philosophers I'm glad
that some of them read it got something
out of it
Kathy Seeger says in the October AMA you
answered a question regarding societal
problems you mentioned among other
things social injustice and how this
could lead to less faith in democracy
following up on that I think it's a huge
flaw in the U.S system to link Health
Care Child Care and College University
education to one's Financial
possibilities and I don't think this how
could eventually I don't see how this
could eventually change because of the
aim for Freedom with very low
involvement of the state in people's
personal lives and the economy how is it
that the American way of life is such a
strong narrative that so many U.S people
are willing to accept the aforementioned
circumstances although so many
inequalities are created
you know
to the actual question you were asking
Kathy I don't know I don't know how it
is that so many people are willing to
accept this and so the question being
begged here is
um could we change the U.S system
without too much trouble in ways that
would be much more Equitable to people
in terms of healthcare Child Care
University education Etc
um it seems like the answer to that is
obviously yes you know the idea that
your health insurance is tied to your
employment status is just bizarre and it
is a big part of why the United States
has similar Health Care outcomes to
other development other developed
countries but spends twice as much money
per person as other developed countries
do because we just have a wildly
inefficient system and also I think
although this is a tougher sell I do
think that it's wildly unfair that the
education you get is so dependent on the
income of your parents where you were
born things like that it would be very
very hard to justify any of that from a
well-balanced moral perspective right I
mean you're you're a baby and you're
gonna start going to school someday but
why should you get wildly different
educational circumstances depending on
who your parents are it's kind of hard
to come up with a justification for that
and so I don't think it would be very
hard to change I mean but it would be so
it's very easy to imagine changes let's
put it that way that would make things
better not perfect these would always
there's always imperfections in the
system but uh it's sort of there's like
obvious room for improvement right but
there's also huge amounts of resistance
to Improvement in that way and some of
it is a little bit sensible because I do
think that when it comes to public
policy one should be conservative in the
old school lowercase C sense that if we
have a system that works pretty well
there is sort of uh reluctance to change
it dramatically because we know our
system works pretty well maybe the new
system will work better but maybe it
will have unintended consequences we
don't know about so I think a tie goes
to the present system in those kinds of
circumstances but like I said I don't
think that this is a very difficult
change to make so I don't think that's
the reason why people are reluctant to
make it I do think that part of exactly
what you said there's sort of a
resistance to let the government control
too much of the flow of money through
the country's economy
anyone who knows anything about the
actual economy knows that an enormous
amount of money in the United States
flows through the government one way or
the other already so that doesn't seem
like a very legitimate worry to me I I
think that ultimately there it's a sort
of psychological slash political problem
um or State of Affairs let's put it in
that more value neutral term
um there's a certain image that people
have that may or may not be accurate of
what government is and what government's
supposed to do there are other images
that people have about what it means to
be fair and what it means to be just and
like I said you know we don't always
think these things through very
logically we don't spend a lot of time
educating ourselves about them
so but I don't know why it's so
different in the United States than in
other developed countries other
developed countries have their own
problems of course and the United States
has its own good things about it
um you know the higher education in the
United States even though it's super
duper expensive and that's going to be a
crisis the research structures that it
supports are the best in the world by a
pretty large margin and I don't think
that's because our Health Care system is
so screwed up but I'm just saying that
I'm not here just to bash the Us com you
know up and down I do think there's some
specific ways in which it could
obviously better and I'm not completely
sure why everyone doesn't agree with me
about that
the winning ticket says if I understand
correctly Einstein learned about Imani
in Geometry from a friend whilst looking
for mathematics to Aid his general
relativity Quest is this a common
practice I.E physicist has an idea and
seeks out mathematical friends
colleagues or literature for unfamiliar
maths to interrogate their idea further
could you conceive of a time when you
may be writing out ideas for a paper
where an AI program could suggest
relevant mathematical theories
so I think that you sneaked in two
questions there but that's okay because
they're very related and good questions
yes it is a completely common thing to
seek out help with uh math problems you
know I literally as I'm recording this I
gave a colloquium my my first physics
colloquium at Johns Hopkins at my new
University
and I mentioned to them that in some of
our work on emergent space-time we
needed to use something called the radon
transform uh the radon transform is a
mathematical technique that is actually
closely related to what you do in a CAT
scan uh when you're looking for an image
of your brain you basically integrate
along some slice you don't literally
slice it but along some plane passing
through your brain and if you do that
for many many different planes you can
reconstruct the whole three-dimensional
image we do a similar thing for space
time I didn't know anything about radon
transforms when we started doing this
um so yeah we had to look it up we had
to figure out how to do it it's great
when you can just ask a colleague about
it usually you're going to start with
Wikipedia or quora or something like
that or maybe if you're lucky enough you
have the right textbook on your shelves
can we imagine a day when it's AI sure
absolutely I think that for the
conceivable future I would imagine
treating AI in a way that I very similar
to how I treat Wikipedia namely it's not
the definitive answer I wouldn't trust
it you know I use Wikipedia all the time
and sometimes non-academics are sort of
shocked like how did why do professors
use Wikipedia it's so unreliable well
you don't rely on it that's that's the
answer you use it to find a pointer to
somewhere else or you know if you just
see a formula that you can redrive for
yourself that's fine I think AI is
exactly the same way in the in its
current incarnations I would not trust
it to do a calculation but if it laid
out a calculation I could certainly
check it right so I'm very uh I I do
think that AI is is capable of doing
things like that that will change how
theoretical and experimental for that
matter physics gets done in ways that
are interesting and hard to predict
herb Berkowitz says when the term spin
is used in relation to an elementary
particle does it mean spin in the same
sense as a planet or a baseball does the
particle turn on an Axis or create
centrifugal force so this is a subtle
question
um it is spin you will read in textbooks
on Quantum field Theory Etc that it is
that the spin of an elementary particle
is not really anything spinning but I
don't think that's quite right and uh my
former collaborator Charles siebens who
is at Caltech in the philosophy
department has done a lot of work on the
quantum field theory of Spin and exactly
this context the reason why they say it
it's not you know they just made it up
and were wrong it's kind of implicit in
the way that you ask the question right
does the particle turn on an axis the
reality is there's no particles
particles are a convenient way of
talking about certain things that we
observe when we measure Quantum fields
in the right way so the reason why in
textbooks they'll say it's not really
little spinning particles because it's
not really a little spinning particle
but it is a field with angular momentum
Fields can have angular momentum and
that's why the angular momentum that is
contained in what we call particle spin
is part of the overall conserved angular
momentum for a larger system so it's not
that there's a little dot or a little
baseball that is spinning it's the field
that has angular momentum and then when
you quantize it and look at it it's a
certain Quantum amount that is what we
think of as elementary particle spin
okay two questions grouping together Dom
says nurtures theorem says time symmetry
leads to conservation of energy however
in general relativity energy is not
conserved is it therefore the case that
general relativity is necessarily time
asymmetric
and Jim Watson says there are various
conserved quantities energy momentum Ang
momentum charge Etc and it is explained
that these quantities aren't really
conserved under certain conditions or
properties of the universe EG in an
expanding Universe conservation of
energy doesn't hold what would be the
properties or conditions of the universe
the conservation of momentum or the
conservation of charge or other
conserved quantities didn't hold so
this is these are tricky questions but
good ones uh the energy one is the
easiest one to explain so it's not that
general relativity is necessarily time
asymmetric it's that the specific
solution to the equations of general
relativity corresponding to our real
world in cosmology is time asymmetric
it's an expanding Universe things used
to be closer together and denser things
will in the future be further apart and
lower density that's the time asymmetry
that leads to energy not being conserved
in general relativity if the background
the if the space-time metric is
completely stationary as we say that is
to say if it's completely the same from
moment to moment then energy would be
conserved but that's not true in the
expanding universe for Jim's question
about angular momentum in charge and
things like that you can always find
places where you have violated this
symmetry that's pretty easy to do this
is the whole subject roughly speaking of
spontaneous symmetry breaking people
will argue over what exactly the
definition of spontaneous symmetry
breaking is but let's put it this way
the Higgs field which has a non-zero
value in empty space and therefore
breaks the symmetry of the electric weak
Theory leads to a non-conservation of
charge of the electric weak part of the
charge essentially because that
background field can absorb the charge
or or change it in some ways depending
on what interactions are going on within
it likewise with the expanding Universe
we say energy is not conserved but it's
not that all hell has broken loose there
is a very definite equation sometimes
called the equation the covariant
equation for conservation of energy
which relates what space-time is doing
to what the energy is so if space-time
is stationary energy is conserved if
space time is not stationary you can say
exactly what the energy is doing you can
say exactly how it changes likewise for
these other things for consideration of
momentum for example conservation
momentum comes from
um the fact that the universe is
spatially translationally invariant it's
the same from place to place
so if you live on a hill that is not
true if you live on a hill then there's
a direction going down a direction going
up and guess what if you put a ball on
the hill its momentum will not be
conserved right now there's a whole
momentum that is conserved for the ball
and the Earth that it's on Etc and
indeed that's because that whole thing
is embedded in a situation where there
is no gradient in space and everything
is spatially translationally invariant
but if you just zoom in on the ball on
the hill its momentum is not conserved
because it's in an environment where
spatial translations are not asymmetry
Michael says you mentioned in a previous
AMA that among your idea of what makes
someone an intellectual is someone who
is in pursuit of trying to find truth
pointing out that politicians may be
intelligent but not intellectuals since
as politicians they're not trying to
figure out what is true and so forth I'm
wondering if living in search of Truth
is what makes someone intellectual does
that mean q Anon conspiracy theorists or
intellectuals since it seems that as
erroneous as they are they seem to
believe they are in some Pursuit some
sort of pursuit of the truth uncovering
what is really true Etc or is it more
the case that using the scientific
method in the search for what is true is
what makes someone an intellectual I
think this is a good slash fair question
because I think I was a little too
simplistic when I when I talked about
what makes someone intellectual for
exactly the point the reasons uh that
you are indicating here so but also I
think that
defining words can be a little bit
tedious right so it's not that there is
some correct notion out there that is
called what it means to be an
intellectual and it is our job as
scientists to find it we are defining
the word to be what we want it to be so
I think for things like this uh there's
two ways to go one is you can try to
restrict your definition of intellectual
to someone who finds truth using certain
techniques or methodologies for example
you would want them to be fallibalistic
right you would want them to be capable
of understanding when they've made a
mistake and therefore fixing the mistake
you might demand that as part of your
definition of what it means to be
intellectual not necessarily the
scientific method we would want you know
logicians and mathematicians to be
intellectuals even though they don't use
the scientific method but you do want to
be able to understand that you've made a
mistake and maybe even more importantly
but less
obviously or less quantifiably uh to me
what would be important is that you are
I want to say sincere in your search for
truth so it's true that conspiracy
theorists think they have the truth but
they're not especially open-minded about
looking for reasons to change their
minds they're not especially careful or
um thorough or honest in trying to make
sure that their worldview is holding
together the right way so I do think
that's a crucially important part of
being an intellectual understanding that
we don't have the final answers that if
new data comes in we have to change our
minds things like that on the other hand
it would be perfectly okay
for with me if you just said sure they
are intellectuals they're just not very
good at it I think we can agree they're
not very good at it and I don't really
think that it makes much of a difference
which of those two directions we go for
our definition you know back in the
early days of the blogosphere in the
early 2000s when there's a lot of
a lot of debate in the science
blogosphere about creationism versus
natural selection and evolution and a
very common move that is still made
today was to say the creationists aren't
science because it's not falsifiable or
because they are not naturalistic or
whatever I always thought that was a
mistake I was perfectly happy to say
that they're doing science they're just
doing it badly you know they have a
hypothesis it's just obviously refuted
by the data I think that it's okay to
admit that you know a lot of people want
to sort of win a battle by making sure
their rules are delineated very very
carefully so that their opponent is not
fair it's not included in the game you
know sometimes you just gotta play the
game you just gotta say like the Q Anon
person yeah okay you're searching for
truth but who are you bad at it have you
done a terrible job and if you're upset
that there's no uh Arbiter of truth no
court of final deciding for what is true
and what is not true welcome to reality
that's just how things are we have to be
able to accept the fact that uh those of
us who do work in good faith and
understand that we can make mistakes are
going to have to do our best in the face
of other people who think they have all
the answers figured out and um are not
going to change their minds about it I
mean I've told the story before maybe
even recently I hated my retail stories
but when you talk on the podcast for a
long time you're going to end up
retelling the stories but there is
um a famous story of a woman who was a
new age spiritualist and you know she
would talk to her friends who were you
know sciency or whatever or Skeptics and
she would explain but then what she
eventually sort of converted or
deconverted whatever way you want to put
it she went to being a complete skeptic
from being a new age person and the
thing that was the crystallizing moment
for her was when she would ask certain
kinds of questions deep questions about
why is there a universal what happened
at the beginning or whatever there are
some questions it wasn't that hard to
formulate for which the scientists or
the Skeptics would say I don't know
and her new age friends would always
have an answer they thought they could
answer every single possible question if
you think you can answer every single
possible question that's not a sign
you're super smart that's a sign you
might have gone wrong somewhere right
that's a sign that you might be
oversimplifying things a wee bit and I
think that's an important tool to use to
remember as we try to do our best all of
us to get more truth in our lives
Anthony Robo says in the last AMA you
expressed disinterest in the explanatory
differences between your notion of many
worlds and that of David Deutsch's you
are really just content with everyone
agreeing on the math it was a bit
startling it felt like in something
deeply hidden you were Champion
championing human friendly explanations
and analogs and did so in several
instances has the Zeal for uncovering
greater descriptive methods around many
worlds truly waned was it just an off
day or have I mischaracterized well it
could be my fault for expressing things
badly but I think at the end of the day
you have mischaracterized what I was
trying to say I mean I'm certainly never
just content with everyone agreeing on
the math but I think that when it comes
to physics in in many ways where science
more broadly there are some ways of
talking about the underlying system that
are either right or wrong and there are
some that are optional right so I mean a
classic example that everyone is going
to agree on I can talk about the box of
gas as a fluid with a temperature and a
pressure and a density or I can talk
about it as a collection of molecules
with positions and momentum two
different ways of talking about the same
thing that's the kind of Distinction
that is between how we divide up the
world in many worlds in many worlds the
common thing that everyone agrees on is
there is a wave function a Quantum state
of the universe
and that Quantum State evolves always
and entirely by obeying the Schrodinger
equation okay that's the theory
that's what you have to agree on if you
believe in in many worlds you notice
that the world many worlds never
appeared in that characterization that's
because how we take the quantum state of
the universe and divide it up into
Worlds is a human convenience
it is a human convenience in exactly the
same way that
talking about the box of gas as he fluid
with or a gas with a temperature and a
density is a human convenience we don't
have to do it
there's not even as comprehensive and
detailed uh description as talking about
all the individual molecules but it is
still true okay it's a higher level
emergent description and there's a
reason why David Wallace who is you know
the leading many worlds guy former
podcast guest his book on everetting
quantum mechanics is called the emergent
Multiverse
because that Multiverse description that
dividing the wave function into branches
is an emergent thing
and in that case the whole thing about
emergent phenomena is they provide a a
true handle on what is going on but at
an approximate level right at a way that
you ignore some information or don't
need to know all the information and can
still get some truth about what is going
on but because it's approximate
different people might actually disagree
about the best way to divide it up and I
think that David Deutsch and I disagree
about the best way to divide up the wave
function of the universe in cases before
D coherence have has happened I don't
think it has anything to do with uh
ignoring the fact that that there's
descriptions or just saying it should be
just math or anything like that it's
just a matter of where you decide what
kind of higher level description you
find most convenient for your point of
view
Zach McKinney says in your conversation
with will mccaskill you two discussed
how the plurality and evolution of
values is essential to the survival and
future well-being of humanity
what would you hypothesize to be the
core values that enable human societies
to survive and thrive in increasingly
hazardous times how might you approach
the problem of quantifying and modeling
the spread of ideas and evolution of
values at different scales within and
across cultures so I don't want to
disappoint you here Zach but these are
way more ambitious questions than I
could possibly answer maybe in my
lifetime much less in this AMA the core
values that enable human societies to
Survive and Thrive and quantifying and
modeling the spread of ideas and
evolution of values great things to
think about
my thoughts on those are going to be
exactly as valuable as anyone else who's
sort of not thought about them very
deeply but a little bit okay so I have
no deep special expert level insights
here
um I do
kind of pause a little bit at the idea
of the core values that enable human
societies to survive and thrive
I'm not sure there are such things there
are values that I think are good
um you know values are things that are
hard to make lists of because they're
not sort of discrete units a lot of the
values like if you say justice is a
value and fairness is a value there's a
lot of overlap between Justice and
fairness John Rawls famously tried to
portray what we mean by Justice as a
version of fairness but other people
portray it differently but anyway
there's a lot of overlap so I don't
think that you're ever going to find the
list of the core values okay having said
that you know I think that
think that we kind of mostly know right
or at least
maybe not I I always wonder about this
because I worry that you know I'm stuck
in some kind of bubble where I think
that the people who I talk to mostly
agree about these things but if you go
throughout history whether you're
secular or religious thinkers and you
want to think about human values
different systems of values often
disagree about this or that thing as as
is very evident out there in the world
but there's other things you see over
and over again right some version of The
Golden Rule treat people as ends not
means do unto others as you would have
them do unto yourself act in such a way
so that your actions would be part of a
universal Maxim whatever you want to
call it different ideas of treating
other people with dignity okay I think
that's a core human value is a human
value that gets in the way sometimes of
a simplistic utilitarian notion of
greatest good for the greatest number
because sometimes maybe you can convince
yourself that you can get a great good
by undervaluing the Dignity of somebody
and that that's why it's it's hard to
write down the fundamental list of
values because I think the greatest good
is also pretty good value let's try to
get as much good as we can right
um you know I think that at a detailed
person-to-person level
the idea of
treating other people not not
necessarily as you would like to be
treated I think it's a little bit
simplistic because other people might be
different than you right that's why Kant
when he was formulating the categorical
imperative was trying to be a little bit
more sophisticated about it it's hard to
put exactly into words what is what is
going on here but the basic idea is that
there is we should act as if there is
some inherent dignity in other human
beings
it's that sounds right you know and you
you say it and it's people are going to
nod along then you can get into edge
cases what counts as a human being you
know does an unborn baby count as a
human being does a chimpanzee count as a
human being just a smart computer count
as a human being and yeah that's fun and
we can think about it but that's why
it's not rigorously done so I think that
kind of and that's also you know it goes
back to the podcast conversation I had
with Paul Bloom about empathy I think
that at a more practical level not just
sort of an Airy fairy what are the
values kind of level but at a down in
the in the grit what what actions do we
take kind of level Paul wanted to argue
that rationality is sort of a better
guide to doing good things than empathy
is and his argument which
psychologically makes sense is that
people are just much better at
empathizing with people who are like
themselves
whereas if we are rational and
Universalist we can say in a more
clear-cut uh focused way that we should
be good to everybody in the world not
just people like ourselves but I think
that at a again at the at the actual
implementation level there's a huge
failure mode for that kind of thinking
which is that it's really easy to think
you're being rational when you're not
that's not to say we shouldn't try to be
rational but I think that
we cannot pay attention to everything in
the world we're going to take in certain
information we're going to ignore other
information
and we might very well be being rational
on the basis of the information we're
paying attention to but that's falling
short of being perfectly rational and
that's why I think the empathy is
important because one way of opening our
eyes to other kinds of information and
concerns and considerations that we
might not otherwise take seriously is to
imagine putting ourselves in the shoes
of other people so one way or another
that kind of idea however you want to
parse it is what I think should be the
core value of human societies taking
other people seriously thinking about
their needs what if I were in their
shoes there's no simple way of putting
it but something along those lines
as far as quantifying and modeling these
part of ideas and evolution values I
have no idea how to do that that's uh
something that I'm not even sure if
that's a well-posed question maybe if we
could hack it down into some well-posed
questions we could we could make some
progress on it
okay I'm going to group two questions
together James Maddox says at the end of
the podcast with Antonio Padilla you
were discussing if the universe is
finite or infinite as someone who agreed
with your arguments on the naturalness
of infinity I was shaken by his rebuttal
of well which Infinity then is there any
Lifeline you can throw to those of us
disturbed by the prospect of living in a
finite universe and then Eric Chen says
what's your own take on the last
question you asked Tony Padilla is
reality finite or infinite what are the
best reasons for taking either view on
this question so I think Eric's question
is very straightforward and I'll I'll
take a stab at answering it James's
question is sort of uh throws in the
interesting you know personal feeling
kind of aspect to it you know being
disturbed by the prospect of living in a
finite universe so my real advice would
be don't be disturbed by anything like
that you're asking for trouble if you're
in some sense hooking your own sense of
well-being to any large-scale features
of the universe as a whole because we
don't know what they are the universe
could be finite it could be infinite we
just don't know so don't be disturbed
one way or the other that I would say
very strongly so as it as twittering is
finite or infinite
I'm actually open-minded about this I'm
more open-minded than I used to be I
used to think it was just infinite
um for basically Arrow of time type
questions I think that
um if the universe lasts forever then it
better have an infinite number of things
it can possibly do because otherwise
we'll just do some subset of things over
and over and over again if there's only
a finite number of states the universe
can be in in an infant amount of time
you're going to be repeating yourself an
awful lot and that gets into various
problems that are essentially variations
on the theme of boltzmann brains one way
or the other
so a universe that has an infinite
number of possibilities and lasts
forever in time is one way out of that
and that's sort of the idea that I put
forward with Jennifer Chen back in her
2004 paper
but there is another thing that you can
say that is completely legit uh on the
table if the universe is finite in both
the number of states it can take on and
in time right so if the universe has a
boundary in time or a cyclic in time or
something like that then in principle we
could imagine a well-posed arrow of time
within that finite period of time I just
don't know how to make that work right I
don't even have a suggestion as to how
that might work but it's completely
possible I do have a half written paper
that I should finish writing someday on
a completely finite discrete version of
quantum mechanics
um which is a both a little bit harder
to make than you think and still
possible still not that hard so I think
it's worth pointing out there but it's
not because I think the universe is like
that it's just because it's important to
be keep open all the possibilities uh as
to what we should
what we should be contemplating when we
ask these big questions I'm in favor of
asking the questions uh I just don't
have strong feelings about what the
answers are
Derek Bain says I'm really enjoying the
new book and for what it's worth I think
it succeeds in making physics accessible
to a total novice like myself thank you
Derek now the question have you dressed
up for Halloween in the past and if so
which of your costumes are you most
proud of
uh yeah you know I like the buttering up
approach to asking the question gets me
to more likely to answer it I'm happy to
do that and um I haven't
dressed up for Halloween in a while to
be honest like it's not one of the
holidays that I do anything special for
usually when I say kid of course yeah
we'd go trick-or-treating dress up for
Halloween probably the best costume was
one that we made uh to look like a robot
so I had a big cardboard box spray
painted it silver and like every
electronic Gizmo and Gadget that we had
in the garage was uh temporarily
attached to the box so I don't know an
amp meter something like that various
bells and whistles there wasn't a lot of
stuff we weren't a very highly
technologically advanced household when
I was a Youngster but uh we did our best
and I thought that was you know at least
a time when I showed some creativity
there usually store-bought costumes were
perfectly fine for me
go to group two questions together here
one is from Ken wolf who says presuming
such things exist if we found there was
a primordial black hole near enough to
send an Orbiter what experiment would
you most likely see done and what
question would you be hoping to answer
and Rue Phillips says if a black hole
were able to come close enough to our
solar system then we could send
spacecraft out to it in our lifetime
what questions would you want to try and
answer that we aren't able to get at
easily with black holes too far to reach
with a spacecraft
well you know black holes are actually
not actually probably that mysterious
in terms of how they behave you know
again it goes to the fact that our
current understanding of the laws of
physics seems to be pretty good so if
you have a medium-sized black hole good
old Einstein's classical general
relativity should be super good at
explaining what it is like we should
have already pretty good picture there's
not like mysteries of black holes that
we need to observe them to figure out
um of course the theory could be wrong
right general relativity could be wrong
so there could be deviations from real
black holes to what is predicted by
general relativity so far we haven't
seen that the best chance to have seen
that so far was in the ligo detection of
gravitational waves it's a little bit
crude because you know you're only see a
tiny little bit of the last part of the
in spiral the two black holes but still
you can try very hard and they do try
very hard to match the predictions of
general relativity to precisely the kind
of gravitational waves that they observe
and the answer is it's smack on it's
exactly right
um so it would be enormously exciting to
find out that the gravitational field of
a black hole was somehow not quite what
was predicted by a general relativity
but that's you know I wouldn't bet on it
if I were if I were there now if it's a
tiny black hole then we have a chance of
seeing Hawking radiation the thing about
Hawking radiation is that the
temperature at which the black hole is
emitting is higher when the black hole
is smaller so if it's a big black hole
it'll be essentially invisible as far as
Hawking radiation is concerned if it's a
smaller black hole there will be a point
depending on what your instrumental
sensitivity is where you can actually
observe the Hawking radiation you don't
want to observe it being too hot because
that means it's about to explode and you
don't want to get too close by but
certainly
observing Hawking radiation would be
fascinating
um again there's a very good chance that
it will just look like what the theory
predicts we have a theory Hawking wrote
down the theory that predicts it so it
would be enormously interesting and uh
well you know revolutionary if we saw
either no Hawking radiation where we
should or we saw Hawking radiation but
it was a different kind of thing we
expected
any one of those would be super super
interesting so the two big questions I
want to know the answer to that we could
test if we were near a black hole are
what is the gravitational field and what
does a Hawking radiation look like we
have very good predictions for what they
should be but any deviations from those
predictions would be very very very
important
Robert ruxandrescue says I had a bunch
of scientific questions on my mind I'm
going to change the topic and ask
something else something that is
important for me bullying when I was
little I was bullied a lot both in
elementary school and in high school the
main reason that I was considered the
school's nerd have you personally had to
deal with bullying if so what did you do
and what was the reason I guess I
experienced a little bit you know I was
a pretty nerdy kid as a youngster also
but I mostly managed to stay away from
it maybe because there were other kids
who were even more fun targets to pick
on than I was I was pick on a bowl but
not very fun to pick on I didn't respond
in the way that they were hoping maybe
but I don't know maybe I'm just
misremembering or maybe there were other
things going on uh I went to a big
public high school there were plenty of
kids to be picked on I do think it's bad
I mean I don't think that there's a
strong pro-bullying Lobby out there so
it's not something that should be very
controversial I presume boom I mean I
guess that there are probably people who
think that maybe it toughens you up
certainly there are kids who are
pro-bullying because they are bullies
right but you know Jennifer my wife
always points out this scientific study
that was done about
um about bullying but it was a weird
kind of study where they they took kids
and you know they had some independent
way of judging you know who were the
popular ones who are the bullies who are
the Nerds who were picked on who are the
outcasts whatever and they had them
watch the Disney movie Dumbo
and you know Dumbo is an outcast Dumbo
is picked on by everybody else until you
know he learns to fly and then he's a
star right but early on he's he's
bullied that's exactly what happens to
Dumbo and so they asked the kids some of
whom were super socially popular and
some were bullies and others of whom
were outcasts or whatever they said you
know who do you identify with in this
movie and the answer is everyone thinks
they're Dumbo everyone thinks that
they're the ones at the end of the day
who are picked on even the ones who you
might have thought were picking on you
they thought that someone else maybe it
was a teacher maybe was bigger kids
maybe it was someone at home someone was
picking on them
so I don't think anyone would stand up
very much in front of uh or in favor of
bullying so the question is what to do
about it and there I don't have any
great suggestions you know I do think
that maybe one tiny suggestion is just
acknowledging the problem right
um to be sensitive to the fact that
things that happen to people when
they're very young can affect how they
turn out when they grow older and not
just imagine that kids should tough it
out and put up with misbehavior on the
part of their peers or whatever to be a
little bit more sensitive to how kids
treat each other you know kids can be
super duper kind and generous and they
can also be super duper nasty and
selfish they haven't learned you know
they haven't always learned to separate
one from the other and learn that it's
okay to be generous and that it's not
okay to be a bully and whatever and I
think that these are things that we
should be teaching our kids and there
are some teachers who are super duper
good and are able to do that and there
are other teachers who don't have that
training or don't have that empathy or
that ability or whatever there are other
teachers who are bullies right and we
probably have all had them along the way
so
maybe the simple thing to do is just to
remind ourselves that we don't do a
great job in
valuing the job that is done by teachers
you know whether it's in terms of you
know social respect or how much they get
paid or the education we give them it's
not necessarily considered a high status
occupation in our society so if we had
teachers who were better equipped you
know and not right not only the training
but also just class sizes resources
things like that
um then maybe they'd be better able to
make sure things like that doesn't
happen in their schools but I don't know
I'm not an expert there I have not spent
a lot of time recently in my life in uh
secondary schools or anything like that
or elementary schools
Sheldon Silliman says I'm guessing you
might consider Evolution as an emerging
phenomenon and if so would you then say
that this emergence implies a strong
possibility that Evolution would operate
throughout the universe is emergence
Universal and how does that work for
such fussy Concepts like culture and
agency so I absolutely think that
Evolution could be Universal you know
evolution is a little bit misunderstood
sometimes there's always a stage in a
young scientific kid's life where they
they hit upon the idea that evolution is
basically tautological right survival of
the fittest well you know who else is
going to survive you're going to define
the fetus as the ones who survive and
they're going to pass down their genes
and that's how it's going to work the
reality is more subtle than that the the
reality of biological evolution is
specifically that there is random
variation tiny random variation in
mature species but there's random
variations from generation to generation
so in some sense The genome is doing a
search through parameter space days
right it's a very inefficient search in
a whole bunch of ways but that's because
it was not designed to be efficient it
was what is naturally happens in some
sense so it doesn't count as Evolution
if you simply have progeny uh it only
counts as Evolution if you have some
information in one generation that is
passed on with the possibility of slight
variations to the Next Generation
that hard to imagine happening right I
mean if you have any life form that is
based on genetic information it's never
going to be passed on 100 perfectly all
the time so I think it would be very
natural for evolution to happen on other
planets other places other biospheres or
whatever and yes it's an emergent
phenomenon uh but that in the very weak
sense it's it's not fundamental right
it's real but it's not fundamental
things that are real but are not part of
our most comprehensive description to
physical reality are emergent whether
it's tables and chairs pressure and
temperature Evolution and culture all of
those things are higher level and
therefore emergent
um as long as you believe the world is
fundamentally physical which I do
Michael monhoft says which individual
steps are happening when two particles
become entangled or disentangled and how
long is this process from not entangled
to entangled approximately take
oops I'm gonna I'm just gonna combine
this together with the next question
which is from Jay Peters a priority
question remember everyone gets one
priority question to ask in their
lifetime and I will do my best to answer
it uh what is the nature of the
interaction among particles that is said
to give rise to quantum entanglement is
it just a matter of spatial proximity
such that the closer together they are
the greater the level of entanglement or
does it have to be some sort of event
that includes both and that establishes
their entanglement well it's
it's there is a difference between an
interaction as such and an interaction
that causes entanglement some
interactions do not cause entanglement
basically what you have to imagine is
that at least one of the quantum
mechanical systems is in a superposition
okay and that's uh there's I'm slowing
down here because there's technicalities
here that I don't want to get into every
system is in a superposition in some
vague sense but if I if I can just get
away with saying you know what I mean if
you have like a spinning particle along
one axis and it's spin up plus spin down
then it's in a superposition or if I
have a particle with a superposition of
being in this position and also in some
other position over there that's what I
mean by a system in a superposition and
then entanglement happens when
um that system interacts with some other
system
in such a way that the different parts
of the superposition interact
differently okay so the example I
usually use is if I have a spinning
particle spin up and spin down
some superposition have spin up and spin
down and I drop the particle then it is
interacting with the Earth because it is
interacting with the gravitational field
of the Earth but it does not become
entangled with the Earth because both
the spin up and the spin down parts of
the superposition evolve in the
gravitational field in the same way to
extraordinarily good approximation so
there's an interaction but it's the same
interaction for all the different parts
of the superimposed quantum system so
there's no entanglement going on whereas
if you have something like Schrodinger's
Cat the superposition is between an
awake cat and a sleep cat and they're in
two different locations the awake cat is
up and walking around the Sleep cat is
lying on the ground sleeping and a
photon can very easily be absorbed let's
say by the awake cat and completely
non-interacting with the asleep cat so
that's an example where the part article
interacts the photon interacts
differently with the awake part of the
cat and the asleep part of the cat and
therefore they will become entangled
okay so that's what it needs that's what
you need to become entangled when one
Quantum system interacts with another
quantum system in superposition
differently with the different parts of
the superposition so spinning particles
do this all the time there can be
interactions there are generally
interactions between particles that
depend on the spin so if you have one
particle simply passing by another one
two neutrons for example let's say and
they're in a superposition of different
spin States the up spin parts of the
neutrons will interact with each other
differently than the downspin parts and
something like that for electrons rather
than neutrons is very often what is used
in designs for quantum computers or
something like that another way to do it
is to create particles that are
entangled from the start so when the
Higgs boson decays the Higgs boson has
zero spin so when it decays into two
spinning particles those two spinning
particles have to be spinning in
opposite directions so the angular
momentum is conserved so we don't
necessarily know which direction either
one of them is spinning in but we know
it's entangled with the other particle
that the Higgs is decaying into because
the two different parts of the super
superposition are connected to each
other in the way that we identify as
entanglement
so Cooper says when you talk about other
universes with different laws of physics
do you just mean their fundamental
constants have different values do you
mean completely different underlying
equations like different terms in gr or
different gauge symmetries in qft
well that depends on the context in
which you're talking about universes
with different laws of physics
specifically in the concepts context of
something like the string theory
landscape okay so the string theory
landscape comes about because we think
there are extra dimensions of space in
string theory they can be curled up and
hidden from our way from our view in
various ways in a large number of
different ways and those ways all give
rise to different low energy laws of
physics different local visible laws of
physics uh and in that sense this is the
basic laws of quantum field Theory
relativity
Etc are still 100 the same from Universe
to universe but the set of particles can
be different you know we have quarks and
leptons and Higgs in our universe so
maybe they only have leptons or don't
have anything that you'd recognize as
quarks or leptons or maybe you only have
spin zero particles or whatever there's
a whole bunch of different possibilities
even if you have the same particles you
can have different interactions between
them either different actual forces so
different gauge symmetries or different
strengths of forces different values of
the cosmological constant you can even
have different numbers of dimensions of
space okay you can have some regions
have six dimensional space some have
three dimensional space Etc but still
all under the general rubric of quantum
field Theory and relativity because the
underlying theory is string theory which
has in the low energy limit Quantum
field Theory and relativity as part of
its description of physics now if you're
not thinking of the string theory
landscape if you're thinking more
generally I can imagine all sorts of
things right I don't necessarily have a
physical mechanism for making them so
whenever I talk about the Multiverse I
try to emphasize the fact that it's not
just saying there's a whole bunch of
universes out there there are physical
mechanisms that can bring these
different universes into existence in
cosmology we have eternal inflation and
we have string theory and these arguably
anyway give rise to a Multiverse with
different laws of physics in different
places and so in that case they would
still be under the quantum field Theory
rubric but with very different particles
forces Etc
Anonymous says the standard model is
called the most successful Theory ever
well isn't it like the most successfully
tuned Theory Ever every time a result
comes in some parameters are tuned to
produce that value and ranges for other
parameters May further be constrained no
wonder the standard model agrees with
experiment
so I don't know where you've been
picking up your physics Anonymous but
that is completely not true it is very
very much not the case that every time a
result comes in some parameters are
tuned to produce that value the number
of parameters the number of experiments
I should say that are done on standard
model particles is enormously larger
than the number of parameters that we
have in the theory it is highly highly
highly constrained because we want to
find a mistake in it right we want to
find that it somehow deviates from the
predictions that we make for example for
the Higgs boson we discovered the Higgs
boson mostly looking at it decaying into
two photons right and that basically
fixed the one undetermined parameter of
the model namely the mass of the Higgs
and then we said okay now we know what
the mass of the Higgs is and then once
you know that you know the rate of decay
of the Higgs boson into electrons and
into top quarks headed to W bosons and
all those things there's no extra free
parameters those are all predictable in
terms of the known parameters and then
we go out and test them that's what
people at the LHC actually do so it is
quite a bit of wonder that the standard
model agrees with experiment it is
highly highly over constrained and uh
remarkably resilient at agreeing with
experiment
Keith says I happen to see the 76ers are
playing the Wizards tonight in your neck
of the woods as they say
any particular fun in person 76er game
memories you feel like sharing as a kid
or whenever
I gotta tell you Keith the Sixers are
not doing well to start the year and I
have had I had very high hopes for them
and continue to have very high hopes
because I'm generally an optimistic
sports fan despite originating from the
Philadelphia area so I hope they get
their acts together but you know right
now I have to say like I I have
different ways for example of going
online and reading things and reading
Twitter or whatever and when things are
going well and basketball and with the
Sixers reading about the Sixers is like
my happy place and I can ignore the rest
of the problems the world has and then
when the Sixers keep losing I'm like
geez there's just no more happy places
on the internet I'm not quite sure what
to do about that
um when I was a kid you know we didn't
go very often to the Sixers games we're
gonna go maybe once a year or something
like that and I do remember going to a
game I don't remember what year it was
but it was before they won the
championship in 1983 but not too long
before so early 80s
um uh watching the Sixers play the
Boston Celtics their hated Rivals and it
was in the Spectrum from the previously
existing building which at the when it
was built in the 60s or 70s or whatever
was state-of-the-art facility but by
later standards was quite a small little
building and uh The Joint was rocking
man when the Sixers would play the
Celtics it would be sold out everyone
would be shouting and they were pretty
well informed fans you know like Larry
Bird on the Celtics would always cheat
and and not play man-to-man defense and
the Sixers fans would start chanting
who's bird guarding because there were
rules against illegal defense back in
those days and uh you know whenever
anyone got fouled which happened a lot
back in those days uh you know everyone
would jump to their uh feet and and
neither Boo or cheer depending on how it
went and uh it was really you know it
was it was a nice painless relatively
um harm-free way of feeling some common
emotional bond with uh your friends in
the fandom of the Sixers so I I and be
and it's all because not only was
basketball fun but that particular
rivalry was so amazing and so emotional
and I hope it comes back I know that uh
Boston did very very well last year
hopefully the Sixers can live up to
their end of the bargain one of these
days and then the Rivalry will be uh
rejoined with gusto
Andrew J says keeping in line with your
thinking about social systems using
ideas from physical systems what role if
any do you think entropy has to play in
macro societal actions is human progress
doomed to Simply shift disorder to
whatever system we have the fewest
problems with be it the environment
International Trade Etc
well I think that you need to be a
little bit more careful when we think
about these big complicated macro
complex systems when you when you invoke
ideas like entropy I think there is a
place for ideas like entropy but it's a
lot more subtle than mixing cream into
coffee right when you mix cream into
coffee entropy goes up but that
statement that entropy is going up is
pretty comprehensive that basically
tells you what you need to know there's
not a lot of new nuances along the way
once you get to biology and psychology
and sociology or even things like
weather or plate tectonics just saying
entropy increases doesn't come anywhere
close to capturing everything that is
going on
um but I think that's an interesting
part of the problem not a reason not to
think about it entropy does go up but
you know entropy goes up in closed
systems which the usual way that we
think of human systems they're not
closed right we interact with the rest
of the universe Us in very important
ways the biosphere on the earth is
dramatically not closed the entropy of
the biosphere is not going up in any
obvious way we get low entropy radiation
from the sun we give it back to the
universe in a high entropy form so the
entropy of the universe is going up but
here on Earth the entropy is pretty low
and and stays that way nevertheless
within some particular system you can go
beyond just saying entropy goes up and
closed systems and you can think about
how different degrees of freedom relax
and locally increase their entropy while
entropy might be going down or being
exchanged or heat is flowing in some way
somewhere else so I don't think it's
simple I don't think that human progress
is doomed to shift disorder around I
think that's way oversimplifying what is
actually very very complex situation you
know one way to put it is the time
scales
for things like I don't know uh biology
like all of biology like the history of
human life or the history of the Sun or
something like that the time scales for
these large-scale systems we're talking
about to come to equilibrium are
enormously larger than the lifetime of a
human being so even though there is some
overall sense in which entropy is going
up the details of the way in which it
goes up matter a lot and maybe that's
you know room for coming up with new and
important principles of physics or of
sociophysics or political physics or
something like that I'm not quite sure
certainly complex systems researchers
care about problems like that
okay Brendan says do you think you're
deep understanding of math and physics
enables you to quickly or easily
comprehend other technical Fields such
as computer science for example are you
able to understand machine learning and
or computer programming with little
difficulty well I certainly wouldn't say
little difficulty I can't even
understand other areas of physics that I
don't already understand with little
difficulty there's always difficulty
involved but also of course there is a
familiarity with certain ways of
manipulating symbols ways of reasoning
or whatever I think that my ability to
pick up something in computer
programming is much better now than it
would be if I had no physics training
but I was otherwise the same person but
it's very very far away from saying
little difficulty
okay Brian Mapes says here's some
numerology
is there anything fundamental about 10
Beyond four fingers plus opposable
thumbs being my biomechanically
successful and even spookier what is up
with 10 to the 10 bits in The genome
neurons in the brain stars in the galaxy
galaxies in the universe enough data for
machine learning Etc
well
um no there's nothing fundamental
fundamental about that at all even in
biological life forms here on Earth they
don't all have ten fingers and toes
right
um I've known plenty of cats who don't
have 10 fingers and toes so and 10 to
the 10 certainly there's no relationship
there but I mean for one thing it's not
even true that that's the number of
galaxies in the universe it's closer to
10 to the 12 and if we're starting to
ignore differences like 10 to the 12
versus 10 to the 10 you're going to find
a lot of quinces coincidences out there
because you're just being quite
forgiving and when you say the numbers
are similar to each other so I wouldn't
draw too much conclusions from that
little bit of numerology
Henry Jacobs says Lottery voting is an
election system wherein a single voter
is randomly selected and their vote
decides the election here are some
positives number one it's a
proportionate representation system
number two voters have more power than a
plurality based system if you model the
voters as biased coins the mutual
information between a voter and the
election outcome decays quadratically
with population size and plurality
systems to Decay is exponential and then
Henry lists a whole bunch of other
positives and he says as you can tell
I'm a fan of this system there are
issues nonetheless you think this is a
good starting point so just to say again
for those of you who are not familiar
with that with this the idea is that
rather than letting everyone vote on a a
candidate or a
um uh some kind of plebiscite or
whatever to actually pass a valid
resolution or whatever rather than doing
that and just counting the votes and
doing the majority Lottery voting says
let's pick a random person within the
electorate and just let them decide
it is easier it's cheaper to do that
than have everyone vote but otherwise no
I am not a fan of this so I'll tell you
why I'm a fan but I even though I'm very
much not a fan of this system
I get it you know I'm I'm not super
duper happy with any voting system and I
think that there is a problem the basic
problem of voting systems before I
answer your question the basic problem
of voting systems is how much should we
care about representing minority
viewpoints right so let's imagine we
have a uh an election between
three people three people are running
for president or something like that and
roughly speaking half the people are
very very happy with one candidate
almost as happy with the second
candidate and cannot stand the third
candidate
roughly speaking the other half of the
people are really really happy with the
ones who the other one hate
are almost as happy with the ones the
other ones put second and really really
hate the ones the other ones put first
okay so in other words there's one
candidate that gets a lot of preference
or a lot of hate there's one candidates
a lot of preference or a lot of hate and
there's a third candidate who everyone
would be happy with under the current
system that person who everyone would be
happy with gets zero votes because
there's another candidate that is better
than them so this is a good reason to
say that we might not in our current
system be taking into account all the
preferences that people have okay
and you can actually even though even
there's even you know rules about
um
there's a there's principles that people
put forward that are supposed to be
things we would want to have be true in
any given voting system and you can
almost always find a voting system that
seems reasonable that violates some of
these rules so it's a very complex and
nuanced kind of thing that I'm learning
a lot about in the physics of democracy
class
I think you said that the the problem
with the lottery voting is the following
imagine that you have a system where 90
of the people think one thing and ten
percent of the people think something
really really different like you're
voting for a candidate and there's like
some 10 crazy fascist racist party right
and then the other 90 of the people are
voting for the regular parties in the
current kind of system or in any ranked
Choice system or any range voting system
um the people the 10 crazy racist
fascists would never win and that's
taken to be an advantage of the system
because the crazy fringes are not
supposed to win but in a lottery voting
system the crazy fringes would win 10
percent of the time and
10 things happen a lot
uh quite a bit right and so there's
actually it is thought to be something
of a virtue of voting systems if they
can sort of smooth out the rough edges
and you know take more or less the
average rather than taking a
representative sample so as Henry says
um Mutual information between a voter
and the election outcome decays
quadratically the population size and
plurality systems Decay is exponential
that's that's a feature not a bug we're
not trying to necessarily uh exactly
represent the will of the people
um including the crazy Fringe people
right now you can debate that that's why
I said at the beginning this is all very
debatable you might make the the point
of view that sure this there could be a
10 crazy Fringe group there also could
be a 10 like really really good group
that also never gets its voice heard
um but I do think that there is
something to be said that if you're
going to live in a democracy
um it's not only that most of the people
should get their way but we should do
our best to get a situation where most
of the people aren't too dissatisfied
so it's it should be more than just
majority rules in my view there should
be a a way in which people who don't get
a hundred percent of what they want are
nevertheless not trampled over and the
worry in a lottery voting system like
that is when those 10 win the 90 are
going to be trampled over and that that
could be bad so some smoothing out of
the extremes I think is actually
intentional and good in a voting system
having said that I don't know what my
favorite voting system actually is so
further thoughts and further persuasion
is welcome
Dory vinnett says not a question but I
think you'd like knowing that my cat
Associates your voice with treats I
often listen to mindscape while making
dinner and now when best it hears your
voice at other times she runs to the
kitchen so I am very pleased to hear
that Dory and I'm glad that you have a
positive Associated association with my
voice bested and I hope that you get all
the treats because you're a good kitty
who deserves all the treats Johann Falk
says what mathematics do you think
everyone should learn in school
regardless of career path
um I mean these are what these are some
of the questions that I don't know I
don't have strong opinions about because
um these are hard questions and I don't
think we should be too glib about them
uh I would like everyone to know basic
algebra trigonometry geometry right the
things that we actually do try to teach
to our students I think you should be
able to plot a function in fact I think
you should be able to know the concepts
of a derivative and an integral even if
you can't do them and this is part of
the idea behind in the biggest ideas
books is that you should be able to
understand what it means if someone says
oh look the maximum value of this
function is where's derivative vanishes
that's not that hard to understand and
everyone should understand that and I
think that we do try to teach those
basic things as John Allen Paulo said
and I completely agree with there are
plenty of things in statistics and
probability
that absolutely should be taught more I
mean just the idea of probability the
axioms for probability basic ideas about
how to use it marginal probabilities
conditional probabilities things like
that some applications to the real world
you know it's not that hard to
understand bases theorem I think that
everyone should understand basis theorem
when they come out of of high school so
that would be nice but you know a lot of
things are nice I don't know what else
would have to go to do that which is why
I can't really claim to have a sweeping
program for fixing methane in schools
Michael Kramer says concerning the past
hypothesis the hypothesis that the
Universe was initially in a state of
extremely or maximally low entropy is
there a way that that might be tested
experimentally so yes and no is the
answer here
um we make observations like we take a
map of the cosmic microwave background
from those observations we infer what
the early Universe was like it was hot
and dense and very smooth from that and
our knowledge of physics we can
calculate the entropy and it was very
low okay so in all that chain of logic
we have made an observation that the
early Universe had a very low entropy
the problem with that logic and with all
logic like that is that it assumes the
past hypothesis because we don't
actually see the early Universe we see
photons landing at our telescope the
connection between the photons Landing
in our telescope and what the early
Universe was like is made on the basis
of assuming that entropy has been
increasing the whole way so that's why
it was dubbed by David Albert correctly
the past hypothesis rather than the past
fact even though we can observe it but
we observe is that it is consistent it
is a self-consistent set of assumptions
to imagine the early Universe had low
entropy that is compatible with what we
see but it's also always possible the
universe had high entropy and we just
randomly fluctuated into existence and
there's no experiment you can do that
can rule out that possibility
Roy Thompson says priority question when
black holes merge how is the mass
converted to gravitational waves any
implication for the black hole
information paradox
well remember mass is just a form of
energy when you talk about the mass of a
black hole you're using E equals MC
squared is there's energy in the black
hole and the black hole in it in its
rest frame is stationary and it has a
mass e divided by c squared so really
the question is what is happening to the
energy and you know there's also energy
contained in the orbits of the black
holes right black holes are not going to
merge unless they're moving so there's
some kinetic energy also and it's all in
contained in the curvature of space-time
all of that energy right that's the only
thing that exists you don't need
any solid material in the black hole if
you had any it would crunch to the
singularity the black hole is a region
of space-time and outside the black hole
is a region of space-time and so all of
the energy in the black holes and in the
gravitational waves is all contained in
the curvature of space-time so there's
no real conversion from mass of the
black hole to gravitational waves it's
one configuration of curve space-time
evolving smoothly according to
Einstein's equation into another
configuration of curb space time where
the energy is the same but now some of
it is moving away in the form of
gravitational waves and I don't think
this has any implication for the black
hole information Paradox because you
don't need to talk about black holes
merging or gravitational waves to talk
about the information paradox
schleier says you've said that you take
the universe to be a closed system
thermodynamically I know some other
physicists don't though I think they are
outliers can you describe the status of
our knowledge here being unbounded
expanding and maybe infinite the
universe doesn't seem much like a piston
chamber
um well our knowledge is very minimal
here right because we're talking about
the universe as a whole about which we
know very little now I think I'm missing
something when you say the universe
doesn't seem like much much like a
piston chamber
it that's true it does not seem much
like a piston chamber the a piston
chamber is a paradigmatic not closed
system there is an external thing that
pulls or pushes on the piston and the
walls of the Pistons move in response to
that and therefore the system inside can
increase or decrease in heat or entropy
or whatever it is not a closed system by
any usual way of thinking the universe
is usually thought up to be a closed
system for two reasons number one we see
no reason why it shouldn't there's no
either theoretical argument or
experimental evidence that the universe
is not closed number two it's not even
clear what it would mean for the
universe to not be a closed system
unless you have some weird definition of
universe a close a not closed system an
open system is one that is exchanging
energy and information with another
system so if our universe was exchanging
Energy Information with another system I
would just redefine Universe to include
that other system too right I don't know
what it would be again there's no need
for any such system on the basis of
theory or experiment but uh my usual
philosophy about these things is to
admit that lots of things are possible
in cosmology Etc but to try to keep
things as simple and as close to what we
already know is true and work out what
would happen in those cases so I think
that just treating the universe as a
closed system is perfectly simple and
compatible with everything we know so
I'm going to go with that Martha
hinrichs says what socio-cultural
rituals and ceremonies do you or have
you ever participated in I.E were you
married by a religious officiant do you
watch fireworks in the Fourth of July
faster during Ramadan
do not festering Ramadan do not watch
fireworks on the 4th of July we were
married I guess by a religious officiant
namely a friend of ours who got one of
those online
um uh religious order you know 25 you're
now a holy man kind of thing in
California that's all you need to marry
somebody but not really very religious
honestly but we did have a ceremony
right we got married there was a
ceremony uh you know we modified our
wedding vows from other wedding vows and
and the whole thing and I take that very
seriously I think that's very
um
I I don't want to say it's important
it's important to me uh it may or may
not be important to someone else I I
think that rituals and ceremonies are
very important but I have no special
attachment to other people's favorite
rituals and ceremonies okay so
um you know Jennifer and I would never
go out for a romantic dinner on
Valentine's Day that just seems like
asking for trouble everyone else is out
and they're all you know crowding the
restaurants and whatever and we can very
easily go out on some other day and have
a very nice dinner likewise uh neither
one of us are big fans of the
traditional Thanksgiving turkey dinner
but we did replace the traditional
Thanksgiving turkey dinner with a ritual
of going to Las Vegas every Thanksgiving
and having Peking duck at the restaurant
Jasmine in the Bellagio that was easier
to do when we could drive there from La
so we're not going to be doing that this
year we need to establish a new
tradition we have various traditi
missions for Thanksgiving for New Year's
for birthdays and things like that so I
think that they're that that I my
personal traditions and rituals and
ceremonies are important but if you're
asking about
commonly shared socio-cultural ones no I
don't have any special
um attachment to those except of course
like sports and things like that which
I'm a big fan of I think again it's a
sort of harmless fun way to get swept up
in the crowd and enjoy their enthusiasm
together as I as I record this
the Philadelphia Phillies are still in
the World Series they may have lost by
the time you're listening to it or they
may have won by the time you're
listening to it
um so the city of Philadelphia will be
very very happy I'm not a huge baseball
fan so I'll be like mildly happy but I'm
not going to go crazy like many of my
fellow philadelphians
Brent Meeker says in mindscape 63 the
solo episode on finding gravity within
quantum mechanics you speculated that
there are only finitely many degrees of
freedom in a given volume wouldn't this
imply that there are also only finitely
many possible States and so there would
be a smallest non-zero probability of
any possible event
the basic answer is no because quantum
mechanics just doesn't quite work that
way to say there's a finite number of
degrees of freedom means there's a
finite number of completely independent
states but in quantum mechanics states
are continuous states are any
superposition of any set of basis States
as we call them so you can have a
particle spin up a particle spinning
that is spin down so that single
particle is literally one degree of
Freedom right it's either up or down
there's only there's only one particle
doing the thing but how many states are
there an infinite number of possible
States because any superposition of
alpha times spin up plus
square root of 1 minus Alpha squared
spin down is a perfectly good State
there's a smooth continuous spectrum of
them and that is why there's no
relationship to anything like a smallest
non-zero probability the probability
does not come from the number of states
it comes from those coefficients the
amplitudes and the amplitudes are
complex numbers they're you know complex
numbers between 0 and 1 in magnitude so
it's a smooth Continuum of possibilities
even if there's a finite number of
states
Sean Bentley says loved your episode on
large numbers with Tony Padilla I'm not
as studied on the holographic Principle
as I could be so apologize for The
Pedestrian question when removing
gravity why do we go from three
dimensions of space down to two and not
four dimensions of space time down to
three
well we do sorry if that wasn't clear so
we have space and time time didn't go
away we do the whole graphic principle
but time is just time it didn't change
we did the holographic principle either
so when someone says you know there's
different versions of holography and in
in the ads cfd correspondence in
particular
um there's a boundary and a bulk and the
bulk has one more dimension of space
than the boundary does but it has the
same number of dimensions of time namely
one so we don't need to keep saying that
over and over again we can just say
five-dimensional space in the bulk
four-dimensional space in the boundary
or whatever and space time just goes
along for the ride
Roman leventov says in the context of
the show with Barry lower specifically
when you discuss how the laws of physics
can explain anything do I understand
correctly that deutschen marletto's
philosophy of science in Constructor
theory is in the middle between human
and anti-human Views that is
counterfactual principles are event
producing real and serve as explanations
whereas dynamical laws which can as
Deutsche and marletto conjecture be
derived from fundamental counterfactual
principles are mere descriptions
I think this is probably a super
interesting question and I don't know
the answer to it sometimes I'll just
read off the question because I think
the question is interesting even though
I have nothing interesting to say about
it in this case I don't understand
enough about what Deutsche marletto
would say Chiara morletto was of course
a guest on the podcast and you can go
back and listen to that uh she's a
proponent with David Deutsch of what is
called Constructor Theory where instead
of thinking of the laws of physics as
saying from one moment and all the
information in that moment I will tell
you what will happen at the next moment
they speak the language of what is
possible and impossible
I suspect that so A Constructor is
something that can that would make
something possible from a pre-existing
possible thing I suspect that it could
go either way you know the the human
view is that the laws are just
convenient ways of talking about the
world the anti-human views that the laws
have an independent existence of their
own and they have some sort of
generative role in bringing the world
into existence so I'm not sure I
understand Constructor Theory well
enough to answer this question but to
the extent that I do I could imagine
playing that either way that you could
imagine that the space of or the
division of things into things that can
happen and things that cannot happen
itself has an independent existence and
brings things into existence by its
continual enforcement of what is allowed
to happen and what is not allowed to
happen or that certain things just
happen and that we speak about possible
and impossible as a convenient way of
summarizing what it is that happens so I
don't think that there is a clean
connection there but maybe one of them
would say something different there
Simon liubinos Says various spiritual
and philosophical traditions claim that
the Universe has a non-dualistic nature
that ultimately the universe and
everything in it is one indivisible
thing and that the apparent diversity we
see is mere illusion I'm not suggesting
that ancient philosophers actually
discovered Quantum field Theory but
theology aside is it scientifically
valid to think of the wave function of
the universe as the only one thing that
actually exists can we even think of
individual objects as being separate
from each other if ultimately everything
is a manifestation of a single field
well I think this is a slightly tricky
question because we come to it with
pre-existing baggage about what it means
for things to be separate or connected
from our everyday life and when we talk
about fundamental physics or the
ultimate nature of reality that
intuition is going to fail us right it's
just not going to quite count so I mean
think of it in a trivial way if I have
um a red block and a Blue Block
now I have two blocks right but also I
have one thing the set of those two
blocks so is it one thing or is it two
things well it's certainly both it's not
like it isn't one thing I have a set of
things and that is a one set okay but
it's also clearly divisible in in an
easy way and the world is like that you
know the world is clearly divisible in a
pretty clear way we do it all the time
it is certainly at the emergent higher
level that we do it but it's still
something that we do I suspect the
universe is just like that I suspect
that indeed the wave function of the
universe is a way of talking about the
universe as a single unified monistic
thing but that it is also very useful to
divide it up into sub factors in fact I
wrote a whole paper about it with
ashmeet Singh called Quantum myriology
um so I think that the categories of
being fundamentally one or being
fundamentally multiple don't fit very
easily onto the question of what the
universe really is would be my take
Kristoff pironsky says I love my cats I
enjoy their unique characters and admire
their Ingenuity but at the same time I
see their intellectual limitations as
they can't grasp complex Concepts it
seems that the jump from a cat to human
intelligence is a qualitative one then
there are quantitative differences
between individual peoples in the
intellectual abilities do you think that
there is another level a qualitative
jump above human intelligence or do you
think that for some reason language
ability generalize being Universal
Turing machines we are at the most
General level already and any progress
from there is just scaling
I don't know it's a very good question
for a couple of reasons
um one is I am not a hundred percent
sure that there is a qualitative jump
from cat to human intelligence there
definitely is a jump and it but I I
guess if if I were really pressed I
might think that a really really really
noticeable big obvious quantitative jump
is indistinguishable from a qualitative
jump
um if cats have an ability to you know
reason abstractly or imagine the future
but that re that ability is just very
very primitive and limited and we have
those abilities that are just much more
developed then it's not a qualitative
difference it's just a difference of
degree so I'm not 100 sure that I buy
the premise of the question
um
there is a Quant qualitative difference
between human intelligence and the
intelligence of a water molecule I think
that that is true because the water
molecule has zero intelligence but I can
imagine that there are higher forms of
intelligence that really if once you get
down to it are just capacities that we
have but enormously stronger capacities
right I mean we're not very logical
we're not very rational we're not very
good at math there's a whole bunch of
ways in which you could easily imagine
improving on human intelligence now if
there is a way to be intelligent that is
qualitatively different then I guess I
might have a difficult time imagining
what that is so on the one hand I can't
rule it out but on the other hand I
don't know what it would be so my
suspicion is that it's just not there
but that I can imagine ways that we
could be more intelligent and so much
more so that it would seem like a
completely different kind of thing from
our point of view
Chris a says somewhat moot now as he's
thankfully been voted out but had
bolsonaro been reelected in Brazil would
it have been ethical to assassinate him
to present to prevent his continued want
and destruction of the Brazilian
Rainforest on which so much of the
world's biological diversity depends
I think there's two ways to think about
a question like this one is in some
abstract philosophy land and the other
one is in the real world in the real
world no it would not have been ethical
to do that uh because if you have a
principle that says that elected
officials who you think are going to do
terrible things can be assassinated then
a lot of people are going to take that
principle and run with it to assassinate
people you don't think should have been
assassinated it's a not a matter of
deserving or not deserving to continue
living it's a matter of who gets to
decide right and the the idea that an
individual should just take it upon
themselves
um to make that determination is one we
do not want to spread around commonly
you know if I can imagine I I don't
think there's a lot of hard and fast
rules in situations like this I can
imagine literally a end of the world
scenario where you have to assassinate
somebody to prevent the end of the world
and nobody else thinks that they don't
see it clearly so they don't get that
and you have to do it yourself fine I
don't think that any current uh leader
of a country is quite in that category
in in abstract philosophy land I should
say the other thing is of course you
could be wrong right you could be sure
that uh this person is going to cause
tremendous harm to the world but maybe
you're wrong so that's why we have
institutions and mechanisms for doing
things like this and it would also be
different if the person were a dictator
in autocrat versus someone who was
elected you can argue about whether or
not the election is fair et cetera et
cetera but in principle if the people
vote somebody in in a democracy then I
would not be in favor of people in the
minority who lost assassinating that
person if they thought their policies
were going to be disastrous
um but then again yeah so to get to
perfect
um philosophy land where we Grant
ourselves the ability to know with
certainty that this person really would
lead to the destruction of the world
then sure go ahead and assassinate them
but I think that the difference between
abstract philosophy land in the real
world in this kind of example is really
really big and important so I don't
think that the in principle conclusion
carries much weight in real world
deliberations here
John Perry says I've just been catching
up and listened to your secrets of
Einstein's equation podcast it seems
inconceivable to me what euclidean that
euclidean geometry was considered to be
the answer without serious question for
so long the sphere for example would
have been a well-known object Euclid
himself with the obvious level of
historical intellect available why do
you think is survived as the single
solution for so long
well I would recommend that in addition
to listening to the podcast you buy the
new book the biggest ideas in the
universe where I discuss exactly this so
sure in three-dimensional euclidean
geometry you could imagine or even
construct a two-dimensional sphere
embedded in that three-dimensional
euclidean geometry you construct the set
of all points uh fixed distance from
some single point there you go a
two-dimensional sphere
and you could talk about the geometry of
the sphere but that's exactly the point
the point is you don't need a new set of
axioms for geometry to discuss
two-dimensional spheres right
you have euclidean geometry and the
two-dimensional sphere is a subset of
the three-dimensional euclidean geometry
that was the difference when people
finally stumbled across hyperbolic
geometry because hyperbolic geometry
negatively curves geometry if you have a
I don't know I mean there's different
mathematical terms for this but if you
have a maximally symmetric hyperbolic
negatively curved two-dimensional
geometry you know we always say it looks
like a pringle or a saddle but those are
not those are just sort of gesturing at
the actual geometry which is supposed to
be completely uniform
that geometry a uniform negatively
curved two-dimensional surface cannot be
embedded in three-dimensional euclidean
space
but it still does have a geometry of its
own so this was an example not just of a
geometry that you derived from looking
at a subset of euclidean geometry but a
wholly new kind of thing
that's why it took a long time to do it
and then of course once you do it you
realize oh I could have done this with
spherical geometry also so in other
words sure people knew about spheres but
they didn't think that you needed a
separate kind of geometry to talk about
them
Paul cousin says how many back and forth
do your papers have to make on average
between you and your reviewers on which
parameter does this depend the most
topic length of paper prestigious
Journal Etc
it's it's very different you know it's
not like there is some median that you
stick pretty close to I've had plenty of
papers just get accepted right away I've
had papers get rejected happily more
accepted than rejected but
um sometimes they're rejected in such a
way that clearly the referees
misunderstood something or you made a
mistake and you can fix it and then
resubmit the paper so it's usually not
that many back and forth like I don't
want to engage in seven rounds of
revising and resubmitting I would just
pick another journal and try again or
even like not even bother like in these
days when you have the archive when you
have online dissemination of papers to
me as an author getting the paper in a
journal is much less important than it
used to be there's better ways even when
I want to look at my own papers uh it's
easier for me to find them on archive
than to find them on my own computer so
certainly that's also true for other
people as well
um but in terms of the parameter that
matters the most
um in terms of getting rejected there's
some
higher Criterion in physics for certain
journals like nature or physical review
letters but honestly physics has a much
flatter notion of journals than many
other academic Fields do in many
academic Fields your papers are just
evaluated by which journals they appear
in certain journals are really really
hard to get into and if and getting a
paper in there is awesome
others anyone can get a paper in whereas
in physics like the main journals like
physical review D have super really good
papers and also extremely boring
run-of-the-mill papers in them so it's
less important to go for those Prestige
journals in physics than in other fields
it does matter how
imaginative let's say I'm trying to
think of a value neutral terminology
here how creative or non-mainstream your
paper is
um in many ways interesting papers are
more likely to get rejected uh and that
sounds bad but it's actually completely
sensible if I just come up with a model
of you know dark matter or inflation or
whatever
that is not
super interesting it just plays by the
rules it does the usual thing I show
that it fits all the constraints and
blah blah blah that paper is not going
to get rejected that's going to get
accepted it's super boring but it's also
correct in its assumptions you know
under under its assumptions the
conclusions follow they're going to
publish it in in a regular old Journal
whereas if I try to be dramatically
different and I say well what about this
brand new idea a lot of people are going
to look at it and go no I don't like
that brand new idea and just reject it
so this this is actually not just me
sour graping there's there are uh
studies that have shown that highly
highly influential papers are more
likely to have been rejected the very
first time they went to a journal then
boring dull papers so and I'm not even
sure how to fix that but I think that
it's something we need to keep in mind
when we think about the role of the
refereeing system
Declan Brennan says does history have a
direction some people looking at the
Ukraine situation think that Russia
doesn't realize the era of colonization
is over others feel that history has no
more of a direction than does evolution
if it doesn't have a direction does it
at least move through phases if it has a
direction can individuals influence it
or are we all just Flotsam on the tides
of historical necessity
I don't think that history has a
direction in any especially useful sense
no I mean sort of like Evolution you
know if you if you follow the evolution
of the whole biosphere there are certain
patterns that emerge and you can call
those directions I mean there's sort of
increasing diversity of species maybe up
until a big collapse right a disaster
hits and a lot of species die off and
then the it starts growing again so do
you want to call that a Direction I mean
I don't really know I don't really I
think that the idea of a Direction
[Music]
implies that either there's something
directing it or that there's some
inevitability about what is going on
because there's a direction right like
if you say oh colonization used to be
all over the place now we don't do that
anymore there's a direction of getting
rid of colonies well you know that might
be an empirically true fact but it
doesn't have any it doesn't have any
control right it doesn't actually have
any influence if one country wants to
have a colony and no one stops them then
they're going to get a colony no matter
what the rest of history is doing so uh
does it move through phases you know
it's absolutely crucial to history that
we can simplify it a little bit a
history book is not simply a list of
every event that happens during some
period of human history like that would
not be sensible we extract from that
remember uh when I talked to Brad Delong
on the podcast he's extremely up front
that he has a grand narrative that he is
trying to use as a lens to you the
economic history of the long 20th
century and that's perfectly good that's
why historians have a job because they
can notice different Trends different
phases that things go through but it's
usually hard to predict ahead of time
what that's going to be we can say after
the fact oh yes here is a a single
historical era or something like that
Malta uble says given the assumption
that the world was created as a random
Quantum fluctuation what is the
probability that it just now happened
rather than happen in the past and from
there dynamically evolved to the current
state
well I don't think this is quite a
well-posed question
um I'm not sure what it means to say the
assumption that the world was created as
a random Quantum fluctuation I know of
No Such assumption
uh there might be random Quantum
fluctuations within the world but I
don't know of any way to have the world
be created is that I know that people
sometimes talk that way but that's
because people are really sloppy
we don't know what happened at the
creation of the world and to say that it
was a random Quantum fluctuation seems
to imply that it was a fluctuation from
something to something else
but if it's literally the creation of
the world then there is nothing
pre-existing for it to fluctuate from so
that's not what it is I mean how long
was it non-existent before it randomly
fluctuated into existence that's not a
sensible question because there was not
even time before that moment happened so
I don't think that that's a an idea that
is really on the market the world was
created as random Quantum fluctuation
there's absolutely an idea on the market
that the world had a beginning
but if the world had a beginning the
world in terms of the whole universe
that just means there's a first moment
of time it doesn't mean that first
moment of time fluctuated out of a
pre-existing nothingness that is
literally the wrong way of thinking
about it it's no more or less than the
statement that the Universe had a
beginning just say that don't say it
came out of nothing or anything like
that
as far as the probability is concerned
yeah I don't know I could easily imagine
a whole bunch of different Quantum
states that give rise to different
probabilities and the quantum mechanics
that we know and love there is a
probability associated with different
measurement outcomes given any one
particular Quantum state but if you
don't know what the state is you have no
idea what the probability of different
possibilities are so again I think it's
a little bit of an ill-formed question
Conor sheffron says unless I've
miscounted you've only had three
episodes that discuss climate change as
a main topic with the most recent being
three years ago it seems like there are
a lot of smart people with expertise in
climate science who are changing who are
saying that climate change is the most
urgent issue facing Humanity at the
moment is there a reason you don't talk
about it more these days
well there's zero connection between
what I think is the most urgent issue
facing humanity and what I need to have
on the podcast otherwise you know I
wouldn't have podcasts about music and
wine tasting and things like that there
are far more urgent issues facing
Humanity that is not the decision
procedure I go through it's more like is
there an interesting thing to talk about
is there something we can learn from
having this conversation and obviously
climate change is super duper important
and super duper interesting but I'm not
going to do a podcast just to sort of
reassure ourselves that we're virtuous
about it just to say you know I never
believed in the therapeutic value of
complaining When Donald Trump won the
election uh in 2016 and you know there
was a period where like you couldn't
have dinner with people without it just
being like Oh no the world is ending
Donald Trump is President things are bad
and I agreed that things were really bad
but my my response was always okay well
what are you gonna do about it like why
are we having this conversation is it
just to get it off our chests like we
just feel bad we want to kind of Yap
about it
um if ineffectually uh and I just never
saw the point in doing that I will talk
about democracy a lot
and I think that democracy is in trouble
but I don't just have a whole bunch of
podcasts saying democracy is in trouble
this is bad I try to analyze the ways in
which democracy is in trouble whether
democracy is is could be improved
whether it can work better there's a
whole bunch of intellectually
interesting questions there when it
comes to climate change there's a whole
bunch of intellectually interesting
questions about climate science and
Atmospheric science and so forth I'm not
especially an expert on those myself and
I'm not quite sure which ones would make
good podcasts but I don't want to just
have a podcast saying climate change is
coming and it's bad I assume that over
95 of my listeners already know that and
I have zero interest in just telling
them something they already know that's
not what we're here to do
tarun says in your recent discussion
with Barry lower you seem to agree that
the human view in relation to laws of
nature is the correct one in comparison
to what you called the God view however
I was then surprised to see that in the
last fill papers survey the majority of
philosophers stated that they accept or
lean toward the non-human view this is
despite the majority having atheistic
views and subscribing to naturalism why
do you think that is
so I think that I didn't want to call
the anti-human view the God view that
was Barry's terminology and he was being
a little cheeky in doing it because
we're both human's you know we're all
humans here just have a good uh slight
poke at our anti-human friends I don't
know of any anti-humians who call it the
God view there is a you know a family
resemblance behind the idea that the
laws of physics have a separate identity
to the physical universe and the idea
that God has a separate existence in
addition to the physical universe but
they're not necessarily connected in any
way there's plenty of atheists who are
anti-humans okay so uh don't take the
phrase God view to literally is what I
would say
James Allen says briefly in your debate
with William Lane Craig you mentioned
that modern physics doesn't use
Aristotelian Notions of cause and effect
is there a place in the literature that
clearly expressed that view such a
citation would be valuable in the
corners of the interwebs where atheists
hang out yes it is the book The Big
Picture by Sean Carroll I can highly
recommend it uh with one footnote I talk
a lot about cause and effect in that
book but
and I and I talk about Aristotelian
Notions as well but because people
continually misunderstand this let me be
very clear I am not an expert on what
Aristotle himself actually said nor do I
really care what Aristotle himself
actually said that's not the point I am
using Aristotle as an Exemplar of a
tradition that puts cause and effect
front and center in our understanding of
the dynamical evolution of the world and
furthermore in front and center in our
explanatory framework of the world I
mean this tradition goes all the way up
at least to leibniz and the principle of
sufficient reason right so it's not
Aristotle himself that is really really
important here what's important here is
the idea that causes are fundamental in
the universe rather than higher level
immersion phenomena that's really the
distinction that is important to me in
that book
Jimmy Jimi says is there an asymmetry
between position and momentum in the
hamiltonian if so doesn't that mean that
there aren't as practically they aren't
as practically equivalent as it
sometimes seems so yeah if you think
about hamiltonians in physics the
hamiltonian is at some level just a
simple way of saying what the energy of
the system is but there's a specific way
in which the hamiltonian comes about
namely when you're using as your
coordinates on the space of all possible
States positions and momentum okay so
the hamiltonian is a function of
position and momentum and it's the
function that says here is what the
energy of the system would be if it had
this position and this momentum read
more about it in the biggest ideas in
the universe where I talk about
hamiltonian mechanics as far as there
being an asymmetry in there it depends
on what you mean by the hamiltonian in
hamiltonian mechanics you're allowed to
write down any hamiltonian you want
and position momentum were perfectly
symmetric you can write down any
function of X and P or any function of p
and X just as well those could be
hamiltonians in the real world the
hamiltonians we actually use to describe
physical systems are not arbitrary
they're kind of specific and in those
specific hamiltonians there is an
asymmetry between position and momentum
one simple way of saying it is
particles will interact with each other
more strongly at least when they are
nearby in position right they bump into
each other or they have an
electromagnetic or gravitational effect
on each other Etc as a function of
position the interaction there has
nothing to do with whether they're
momenta or close to each other right
there's no no principle in the real
world that says if two particles have
the same momentum they will interact in
some strong way that's just not a thing
and that difference can be traced to the
fact that P and Q momentum and position
appear differently in the hamiltonian of
the real world
Joshua hillerup says do you think poetic
naturalism could be applied to ethics
for instance could there be some sort of
fundamental consequentialism that's
about as useful for making actual
ethical decisions as the standard model
is for engineering a building but it
could be used to build up other ethical
theories more specific to given domains
in a similar chain to what we see in
science
I think that's very possible you know I
think that Joshua green actually
gestured in this direction where he
tried to say that he didn't perceive as
much of a difference between
utilitarianism and deontological
theories as some people do and even will
mccaskill you know said that we can sort
of consider the median or some
superposition of consequentialism and
deontology however I don't necessarily
know that the fundamental level would be
consequentialism I mean I think the way
that I would put it is what you could
say is is there some
fundamental moral theory and it doesn't
need to be objective it can be something
constructed that's fine but is it it's
supposed to apply to all situations all
circumstances and be Universal in some
sense even if not everyone agrees with
it but some people do if there were such
a theory but that theory were so
wickedly complicated in practice that we
would you know get in trouble if we had
to sit down and work out what the
consequences of that theory were in any
particular circumstance so instead we
use rules of thumb and approximations at
higher levels I think that's extremely
possible whatever that fundamental level
actually is and probably something like
that is what we actually aspire to do in
the real world
Paul C Conte says I was wondering now
that you're at Johns Hopkins if you
would be given any preference in
submitting an observation proposal for
the jwst if you could submit an
observation proposal to the committee
what cosmological or astrophysical
question would you consider
investigating
well I'm allowed to consider to submit
observation proposals as far as I know
there is no preference for Hopkins
faculty for jwst I don't know if you're
an astronomer yourself but very often
universities or research institutes will
buy a fraction of a telescope right so
you have a big telescope that has many
institutions using it but you know like
the Keck telescopes in Hawaii were joint
between Caltech and the University of
California so
there's different University of
California campuses and there's Caltech
and the professors at those institutions
absolutely get preference when it comes
to submitting proposals the jwst is a
NASA facility so if anyone is going to
get preference it's going to be NASA
employees I don't even think that they
get preference to be honest I think it
is supposed to be a national or even an
international good the Space Telescope
and so anyone can apply to it I myself
have zero plans on proposing anything
like that I'm going to leave that to The
Experts you know it's it's the kind of
thing where you got to know what you're
doing it's one thing to say I would like
to observe something but there's a lot
of real
um knowledge of how it is done practical
knowledge right
um that you need to learn the hard way
by training with someone who knows what
they're doing and learning and stuff
like that and as a theorist I haven't
done any of that so I'm going to leave
that to The Experts if I have a theory I
want tested I'm not going to put in a
jwst proposal I'm going to go to my
friends who are good at this and say you
should test my theory that I might very
well do
nalita s says what is from your
perspective preventing us from finding
Dark Matter given its immense influence
do you think we will ever be able to
spot it like we did other Elementary
particles
well that's certainly the hope you know
there's no
as Martin Reese has said former
mindscape guest now that I think about
it
um
it's not surprising that there is dark
matter in the universe in the sense that
all dark matter is is some particle that
has a substantial abundance of mass in
the universe that doesn't interact
either through the strong interactions
or the electromagnetic interactions how
hard is that that's not it's very very
easy to come up with ideas for particles
like that indeed neutrinos are
absolutely particles like that they are
not the dark matter that we know about
in cosmology at least we don't think
that they are because they move too fast
okay they're too low mass and high
velocity to fit the detailed properties
that we think dark matter has they would
be hot or warm Dark Matter whereas cold
dark matter is what fits the data but
they are an example of particles that
are dark and our matter so there you go
and we've detected them also so we
absolutely hope to spot it uh we've
talked about that on the podcast of
people like Lina nasib if you want to go
back in the archives
um but we haven't spotted them yet so
we're still looking I don't know you'll
know if we find it you'll definitely
know
Brent Jones says I teach AP Chemistry
and AP Physics at a rural High School in
West Virginia and I absolutely love
going to work every day now that you're
teaching again I'm curious to know what
you love most about teaching
ah it's probably the wrong time to ask
me that as I'm kind of swamped with
teaching right now there's a lot of work
involved in teaching apparently who knew
about that but you know there's there's
so many things that I also love about it
and I can't uh deny that you know I love
it when I'm able to say something that
suddenly makes a little light bulb go
off in the student's head especially
when that light bulb is oh no I've been
misinformed about something my whole
life you know I'm teaching a an upper
level undergraduate seminar on the
philosophy of physics and there's plenty
of places where you can point out that
you know here is what we get taught in
our physics classes and here is the
completely different truth and you see
the students go like oh my goodness yes
I was taught that you're right and so
that's always fun
um it's also just fun to
talk individually to the students you
know to me the years of your
undergraduate education are
in many cases the most important
informative of your life because you
know you go from having been in the same
environment or very very similar
environments for most of you going up
and then suddenly you're in a completely
different environment with completely
different friends learning new things at
a high level doing different things and
then that sort of sets you on the
trajectory of the rest of your life so I
worry a little bit you know you talk to
students and you always worry that
you're going to say something that will
turn out to be really crucial for their
life and you were just you know saying
it kind of randomly so there's a
responsibility there but I do like the
idea that I can help students navigate
this very very important and fraught
period of their lives
um I I have usually in my teaching past
been teaching upper level physics
classes where the students were more or
less on a trajectory already you know
either graduate students or very upper
level undergrads now I'm teaching a more
diverse set of undergraduate students at
different levels of their
career and so a lot of it is like yeah I
have no idea what I want to major in yet
right and and there are a couple words
here and there can have a big impact so
it's something to be to take very
seriously
Dave says according to Black Hole
hologography does Hawking radiation
convey information about the state of an
object when it hit the Event Horizon
only or rather a history of all of its
states inside the Event Horizon until it
hits the singularity
well you know technically there's no
difference between those two things uh
if you believe that information is
conserved which is one of the motivating
ideas behind holography Etc the
information from one moment to the next
is the same information just sort of
scrambled by the historical Evolution so
knowing the whole universe a la
laplace's demon at one moment of time is
equivalent to knowing it at any other
one and that goes also for objects
falling into black holes so we talk
about the quantum state of the black
hole as if it was a constant thing but
even if it's evolving it goes from one
state to another in a way that is
strictly determined by the equations so
that set of information whatever it is
however you want to present that set of
information that is what is supposed to
be taken away by the Hawking radiation
if information is conserved
Redmond says on atheism does a strict
materialist who rejects not only
traditional concepts of a deity but any
higher organizing principle whatsoever
assume the burden of proof
well short answer no longer answer is
what do you mean the burden of proof
burdens of proof are an idea that that's
a concept that applies in a legal
proceeding okay prosecutors have the
burden of proving that the guilty person
really did it Beyond Reasonable Doubt in
a civil proceedings the burden of proof
will be different and so forth if you're
just talking to someone and you are
mutually trying to find the truth no one
has a burden of proof you're you should
be working together okay it's it's very
very using legal proceedings as a
paradigm for finding the truth is a very
very bad way of finding the truth let's
put it that way there's much better ways
of doing it as an intellectual Endeavor
if what you mean is does this does
rejecting traditional concepts of a
deity in a high organizing principles
somehow
deserve less apriari Credence than
assuming a deity or whatever then no
that doesn't seem at all right to me if
anything assuming a deity is one extra
thing to assume and therefore you should
have a reason for doing it but I
wouldn't call that reason a burden of
proof
Jeff B says imagine that a simple object
like a paperclip is floating in empty
space for the sake of arguments suppose
that the paper clip is shielded from
interacting with the environment in any
way now we could imagine waiting some
amount of time and observing the paper
clip am I correct in saying that the
longer we wait the more branches will be
created when the paper clip is observed
if so is this mostly due to the larger
number of radioactive decays the paper
clip has undergone or is it mostly due
to the paper clip gradually spreading
out over Hilbert's space
you know I I always a little leery of
questions involving counting number of
branches if the number of branches is
infinite there's no way to count you can
integrate over certain sets of branches
and get a weight that you can apply to
them but the total number is infinite so
it's not like it there are two more
branches in some period of time or
anything like that
the the interesting part of your
question the quantitative part
um I mean I do think that in some sense
you know at least morally yes more
branches are created the longer you wait
to observe it
um you don't have to put it in a box to
make that true you don't have to Shield
it from interacting with the environment
just let it interact with the
environment and branches will be created
all along and the number of branches
created are not any different if you're
just looking at the paper clip the whole
time then if you're letting it float
freely in space and both of the effects
that you mentioned a spreading of the
wave function of the paper clip itself
and the fact that there are radioactive
elements within the paper clip they will
both contribute to
um branching the wave function of the
universe how many of them yeah I have no
idea as I said I truly don't care about
these questions about counting the
number of branches that's just not where
the interest to me lies maybe that's an
answerable question but I just don't
know what it is
Chris Murray says in a closed Universe
if you put many black holes close
together in a straight line all the way
around the universe could they merge to
become a black tube with a stable
cylindrical Horizon and what would that
be like
this is a very interesting question
because the short answer is no they
would not be a black tube of the stable
cylindrical Horizon but it turns out
that that answer depends on the number
of dimensions of the universe and also
on the size of the universe so there are
called there are things called black
strings so uh you know a black hole but
rather than being a sphere it's like a
one-dimensional tube just like you say
not an hour three plus one dimensional
space time but maybe in compact
dimensions of space you could have such
a thing and the reason why I would not
be stable is you can increase the area
just by beating it off into individual
black holes and that increases the
entropy and that's what you want to do
in terms of what black holes tend to do
you always want to increase your entropy
Casey Mahone says experiences of
aesthetic Beauty can sometimes feel
Transcendent and divine but from a
materialist standpoint these experiences
must be rooted in our Evolution what do
you speculate as The evolutionary basis
for these sorts of overwhelming mystical
or artistic experiences well I don't
know is the short answer but I can at
least say that it's completely
unsurprising to me that there are such
mystical or artistic experiences you
know the human brain is a complicated
Place evolution is a complicated process
right it's not a straight line design in
order to fulfill some goal the shifting
demands of our environment and the
situation we're in put different
evolutionary pressures on our brains at
different times and also because it's
not designed we have to work as
previously mentioned with this framework
of looking at random fluctuations in the
underlying blueprint from the DNA and
seeing how they play out in the real
world which is a very Hit or Miss way of
doing things so we end up with systems
in biology whether it's the brain or
otherwise that are you know in many ways
not well designed like enormously
powerful but a lot of redundancy in some
places fragility in other places
inexplicable wiring choices and yet
other places and so forth so it's not
that we are evolutionarily chosen to
have Transcendent experiences but maybe
there is some reason or even maybe it
was just random that transcendent-like
experiences played a good role you know
being happy not being drawn down or
depressed by the moment
um sort of being able to think more
widely about big questions these are all
things that I can imagine have a good
evolutionary purpose to them so I don't
know the specific answers to this
question but the brain is a complicated
place and and it makes zero
um
zero difficulty in my mind to imagine
that something like that could evolve
Floyd Aldrich says could you explain how
a dragon would breathe fire in the
fantasy world
so this is another one I think I'm
getting more and more interested in
picking questions to which the answer is
I don't know
or you shouldn't ask that question but
for this one you know this is I don't
want to read too much Floyd into your
asking of the question but there's a
whole genre of discussions that I I'm
very familiar with having worked as a
consultant on Hollywood movies and so
forth which is taking something that
appears in a fantasy or or not very
grounded science fiction story and ex
post facto trying to come up with a
sciencey plausible explanation for it
okay the real answer is because the
author wanted them to that's how a
dragon can breathe fire dragons don't
really exist they couldn't be able to
fly if they did exist and so why not
have them breathe fire it's kind of fun
right that's the actual real answer
now if what you mean instead is
um what is the most biologically
physically plausible way to get a
biological creature to breathe fire that
I also don't know the answer to but it's
actually not that difficult to believe I
mean probably just for safety
considerations what you would want is
not to actually be able to breathe fire
but to belch some sort of Highly
flammable gas in an environment where
things light on fire all the time by
themselves because there are sparks or
electrical
currents or something like that right
that seems to be a little bit more safe
than actually starting a fire inside you
and then breathing it out that doesn't
sound very safe at all and if that's the
way you're doing if you're just belching
out gas we belch out gas all the time
there's no special evolutionary reason
why the gas should be highly flammable
but if you really really really wanted
it I could imagine that an organ is ISM
could do that so that would be my guess
there's probably other ways to do it
um
an even better way if you were able to
design rather than just build it
biologically what you might want is to
have two gases which are separately
perfectly stable but then when they're
combined they become highly flammable
um that happens all the time it happens
in rocket ships right hydrogen and
oxygen can be kept separate but then
when you put them in the same region of
space they burn very very easily so that
might be another way for dragons to do
this I don't know how dragons get a
large collection of hydrogen in them but
it is a fantasy world after all
Christopher Becks says I recently read a
New York Times article about a German
heiress leading a movement to have
massive inheritances go almost
completely to taxes and redistributed by
the government the thought being that
redistribute redistribution versus
philanthropy reinforces existing power
structures by allowing the ultra wealthy
to decide where the money goes I'd like
the spirit but feel like it puts a lot
of faith in government to use this money
well and actually reinforces
international power dynamics by keeping
money in countries with more ultra-rich
people
well it's always you know compared to
what okay so I presume that what you're
imagining or contemplating is comparing
some very severe kind of inheritance tax
that uh when people die their fortunes
are heavily taxed versus letting the
wealthy family keep it and decide how
best to philanthropically
um
spread it around
I I don't want to eat the rich or kill
the rich or anything like that as I've
often said uh I'm in favor of rich
people I wish I were a rich person
um and I'm I'm okay with allowing rich
people to enjoy their money to some
extent at the same time I do think that
there should be inheritance taxes uh and
I think they probably should be a lot
more than there are and I think that the
argument that well then the government
has to use that money well is pretty
easily defeated by the I by just looking
at how the government would typically
use that money versus how a wealthy
individual might use that money many
wealthy individuals are very good at
doing philanthropic good to the world
but it's it certainly has the failure
mode that you have someone with quirky
interests right
they have a lot of money and they're
going to spend on things that they think
are interesting and that's that's their
right to do so I'm not against that but
the government has different interests
the government has the duty of thinking
about how best to spend all of the money
on all of the needs that people have and
do so in a responsible way does the
government always do a good job at that
no but at least that it's their job and
we can try to make them do a better job
at it so I'd be very much in favor of
all sorts of higher taxes on richer
people
um and then and then separately work to
make the government spend the money as
well as we can it's you know very down
to earth kind of boring policy proposal
but I'm in favor of that
Peter solvest says in episode 200 you
seem to make the argument that
considering yourself as a boltzmann
brain is cognitively unstable so we
shouldn't think of ourselves as
boltzmann brains and thus should assign
lower credences to theories that predict
there are a lot more Bolson brains than
other observers I follow the logic to
not thinking of myself as a boltzmann
brain but why should that give me the
leverage to lower my Credence about
cosmological theories that predict them
in other words I get that I should
behave as if I'm not a boltzmann brain
for practical reasons but why should
that give me theoretical grounds to make
any statements about which theory is
better
well I'm not sure I quite buy the
difference between the two things uh
behaving as if you're not a boltzmann
brain for practical reasons but not
theoretically accepting it uh I think
that you should behave in accordance
with whatever view of the world you
actually accept is likely to be true and
the point about the cognitive
instability of boltzmann brains is it's
no way to go through life accepting that
because you can draw no conclusions you
do not know anything about the world if
that's the cosmological scenario you
accept I don't think there's a
difference between saying I think this
is true but I'm going to act as if
something else is true I I can't imagine
a principal justification for doing that
you might be in trouble if we lived in a
world where there was no better Theory
right there was no way to assume that we
were not boltzmann brains and get a
coherent picture of the world but there
is it's pretty clear that we can assume
we're not Bolson brains that there is
actual regularity in the world there's a
low entropy pass that we evolved from
and all that stuff all that fits the
data really really well so you do have
the ability to construct cosmological
models that are both potentially true
and sensible and fit all the data I'm
going to Advocate doing that
virus says I've noticed that whenever
scientists talk about the state of the
universe and Associated big theories
they never really add the small asterisk
that it's all from the perspective of
humans and from our location in space
do you think this creates a form of
scientific absolutism where we fail to
recognize that the rules that govern our
reality only really make sense from our
Observer status from our perspective
well yes and no I wouldn't put it that
way I mean the short answer there is no
but it is absolutely true that we are
highly conditioned on what we are able
to observe sure there are some things
that are easier for us to observe easier
for us to notice than other things and
that guides our scientific theorizing
there is a reason why Aristotle and
Galileo and Newton came up with their
theories before we came up with quantum
mechanics in the standard model and
general relativity and things like that
our knowledge of the world was much more
limited back then uh but it's not a kind
of absolutism Newton I don't know what
Newton thought but he should have
thought that you know maybe someday
we'll know more and change our minds
right that's what we do as scientists we
do our best to understand the universe
to under uncover the patterns the laws
that it obeys and we imagine that maybe
those patterns and laws continue to be
true elsewhere and then we test that
idea we say if that's true what would we
predict what would reserve and we go
looking for it that's how science works
and we need to be careful of our biases
Etc but we got to work with what we can
work with that's and there's no
absolutism about it
crafter Luca says why do you think many
worlds is still not the consensus View
for the foundations of quantum mechanics
it's perfectly good reasons why many
worlds should not be the consensus view
I don't think they're right but they're
decent reasons I think the basic reason
is the simple fact that the metaphysics
the underlying view of the world
presented by many worlds is radically
different than the view of the world
that we're familiar with from our
everyday experience and on the one hand
you should expect something like that I
mean who's to say that the true
underlying theory of reality should in
any sense map in any easy way onto our
everyday experience but on the other
hand when you actually have a proposal
for the underlying structure of reality
you should be cautious right the thing
about many worlds is it's a very easy
Theory to State there's a vector in the
Hilbert space and evolves under the
Schrodinger equation but there's a lot
of work to be done in connecting that
simple underlying Theory to our
observations and our experiences and
there's an obvious way to go wrong if we
think we know already what our
observations and experiences are look I
I wrote a paper about deriving the born
rule from the many worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics with chip siebens
we've already mentioned and I think that
I agree with the logic we put forward
there
but I have to be honest in that we knew
the board rule ahead of time so we
weren't going to write a paper deriving
a different rule right so it's easy to
fool yourself in those situations and
exactly because the fundamental
structure of reality suggested by many
worlds is so different than the world we
observe it's perfectly okay to be
cautious to be tentative about it and
other theories map on more directly to
the world in a hidden variable Theory
the reason why you see particles is
because there are particles that's very
that's very basic in an objective
collapse Theory the reason why wave
functions seem to collapse is because
they collapse and that makes the theory
uglier and more complicated and harder
to generalize but also easier to
understand in a very direct way so
that's okay eventually everyone will be
on the side of the angels and agree that
many worlds is right
Steve glor says do you have any
anecdotes about your interactions with
William Lane Craig I've seen quite a few
wlc debates and yours is probably the
one that has challenged his scripted
talking points the most effectively you
had some help from Alan Guth as I recall
what are your Recollections of the times
you have debated him any chit chat
before or after thinking back are there
any additional things you wish you had
said or things you would now put
differently
um you know we didn't Chit Chat that
much we chit-chatted a little bit we
didn't like pre-plan anything for the
debate he's he's debated many times he
has a system you know we're not going to
deviate from the system it's it's either
when I get invited is he like do you
want to do this or not you know there's
no negotiations
um and we only debated that once so I
don't have repeated interactions we did
go out to dinner afterward but we went
to dinner with like 20 people so even
there there was not a lot of Chit Chat
he is very gracious you know he
complimented me on my debating at the
end of the the whole thing I didn't
convince him of anything you know he
later wrote a bunch of blog posts and
did interviews explaining why I was
wrong uh which is not surprising
um as far as what I would have done
differently uh I don't think I would
have done that much differently but I
would do it differently were we to do it
again I don't think we will we have no
plans you know this life is short and I
did that once I'm not planning on doing
it again but if if I change my mind and
the world changes and we do do it again
I would approach it very differently not
because I think I shouldn't have
approached it the way I did but because
I already did that so there's a
different way to approach it and the
approach I took in the actual debate was
I'm not interested in winning the debate
in the sense of you know a high school
or college debate competition I was on
the debate team in high school I know
what it means to win uh you know to go
Point by Point by an argument and refute
the arguments Etc but that's a very very
stylized way of discussing things it has
nothing to do as we already said
previously with the burden of proof and
legal proceedings it's not about the
search for truth right so my goal in
that debate was less to sort of score
points and more to explain myself more
to be understood given that there is an
audience and some of those I mean it was
literally at the New Orleans Baptist
Theological Seminary right so the
audience was stacked against me but as
long as they're young people I don't
mind young people will always listen old
people are a whole different story
um but I wanted to help them understand
why someone would be an atheist and yet
be rational all and even maybe a good
person right that was my goal and so I
hope that I uh succeeded at that you
know like why the arguments from William
Lane Craig were not logically airtight
because they are not and also why there
is an alternative that works very very
well
um so
in the you know we each like he spoke
and then I spoke and he spoke and I
spoke and he spoke that I spoke and by
the last of my three little speaking
slots it was short but I had already
said everything I wanted to say right I
mean I refuted his argument and his most
recent uh his in his final speech I
don't think that he said anything new or
everybody in any of my arguments so I
didn't even try in the third part of the
debate to refute anything he'd
previously said I think that I had done
that already so I just gave my sales
pitch for why naturalism is a very
fulfilling and rewarding way of thinking
about the world
um and I think that's exactly what I
should have done and I'm very happy that
I did that if we were to do it again
maybe I would actually try to win the
debate in the sense that I would you
know having given my sales pitch for
naturalism maybe I would just focus in
more on why his protheism arguments
aren't that compelling uh or maybe not I
don't know but that would be a different
style which could be equally effective
depending on what your goals were
Claudio says I lived 32 years in a
country with mandatory voting and 20 in
a country where voting is not mandatory
I strongly favor making voting mandatory
my rationale is that for proper
democracy the government must be
representative this is its composition
should be as proportional to the people
as possible what's your position on
mandatory voting you know I don't have a
strong feeling
um this is a case where I think that the
whatever feeling you do have should be
informed by the data in other words I
don't think that there's any
philosophical or moral argument that
would completely persuade me to be
either for or against mandatory voting
but if it actually in the world led to
better results then I'd be in favor of
it I don't actually know any sort of
unbiased systematic survey whether or
not it leads to better results or even
what it means to say that it leads to
better results so therefore I'm agnostic
on that one
Brian says Antonio Padilla said that we
can't picture Graham's number because it
contains too much information but then I
wondered can you picture pie there
aren't enough atoms in the universe to
do that in your head either but we have
it defined same for Graham's number
maybe the question is what is the
significance or are there any
implications from the fact that we can't
hold it fully in our heads
so you're right that in the case of both
pi and in Graham's number we have a
definition of it okay and we can write
down that definition in a finite number
of bits finite number of instructions to
calculate the number but if we were to
actually write out the number the story
changes a lot Graham's number is very
very long Pi is literally infinite okay
if you write out the entire decimal
expansion of Pi it never ends so there
was never any question of holding the
decimal expansion of Pi in your head
it's just Infinity is bigger than a
finite number so you can't do it now
it's sort of not an interesting
conjecture the thing that Tony was
making uh the point he was making about
Graham's number is that it is a finite
number you might think you could hold it
in your head right no one ever thought
you could hold all the digits of pi in
your head but you might think you could
hold the digits agreement number in your
head but you can't because the storage
capacity of the brain that would be
necessary to do that would collapse into
a black hole that that is the
implication so it's a little bit
different just because Graham number
Graham's number is long but still has a
finite length
I'm going to group two questions
together James Swift says I sometimes
struggle with how mathematicians use the
phrase solve the equation it's easy to
understand when someone says solve f for
X but when just generally stated
statements I'm I'm sorry I'm reading
this with a bad inflection here but when
just generally stated statements like
short Shield solved Einstein's equation
I feel a little lost can you give
guidance about how to understand such
statements what is being solved and
Billy westum says I'm trying to learn
some Basics about Einstein's field
equations and I'm I feel I am missing
something simple in my understanding of
the significance of them before and
after they were solved where Einstein's
equations in 1915 simply incomplete but
still obviously important what does it
mean for an equation to be revolutionary
without Solutions yet fined found
um yeah so I mean I wanted very much to
answer this question but you're kind of
making me feel bad because I'm realizing
that this notion of how having an
equation and solving it is perfectly
clear to me but maybe I didn't make it
clear in the book or elsewhere and it's
not fair to think of it as an obvious
notion because it's not an obvious
notion the notion is if you have an
equation like two plus two equals four
that's an equation there's nothing to do
with it you can't solve that equation it
just is the equation but when you have
algebraic or analytical equations you
have equations with undetermined
parameters in them you have not just
numbers but symbols to put it very
basically right you've you've elevated
your mathematical technique from numbers
to letters
so let's say you have x squared equals
four x squared equals four is also a
perfectly good equation but you're not
done when someone hands you that
equation here's x squared equals four
that's the equation the question is what
is X right and you know the answer X is
2 except also x equals minus two so
there's two solutions and that's a
little bit of a subtlety that you can
talk about but finding the actual value
of x that satisfies that equation is
what we mean by solving it an Einstein's
equation in general relativity is
exactly the same structure except what
you're solving for is the metric the
geometric quantity that tells us the
curvature of space time so we have a
metric it's G mu Nu if you're reading
the book and what we do is we write an
equation containing G mu Nu in various
forms but the equation itself doesn't
instantly tell us what the solution is
what the actual value of G mu Nu is
so when Carl shortshield solves
Einstein's equation we had the equation
but we didn't know that there was a
solution of the form G mu Nu equals the
short Shield solution okay so Einstein
when he wrote down his equation in 1915
the equation was complete it was done
and he instantly solved it in various
approximations in fact he honestly he
had essentially solved it before he
wrote it down because he had approximate
versions of the equation itself but he
didn't have any interesting Exact
Solutions those came later so you can
propose a solution an equation and have
a very good reason to believe that it is
correct
um not you can't be sure because you're
never sure in science but you think it's
correct without yet knowing what the
solutions are Einstein's method was to
find approximate Solutions and that's
why he could still explain things like
the deflection or the procession of the
orbit of mercury for example he could
show that that was a prediction of his
equation without solving it exactly
because he was solving it approximately
Brendan Hall says do you ever do
problems or exercises from a textbook
when you're learning when you're trying
to learn a new subject these days
you know sometimes
um I'm not that devoted to it
but I guess the reason I want to answer
the question is to emphasize that
there's a part of learning which one way
or the other is the equivalent of
solving exercises from a textbook like
and this is precisely what we don't do
in the biggest ideas in the universe
that's what makes it possible to fit all
that information into such a short space
in the book we don't tickle that part of
your brain we do not teach you how to
solve exercises or solve the equation
Etc so I'm a very firm believer that if
you truly want to learn something you
can't just know the equations but you
have to know techniques for solving them
for doing the problems for doing the
exercises and that's really how you
learn it as unpleasant as it is in your
student days
um so if I am you know my I I don't have
a good example right now off the top of
my hat but I have well here's an example
I have a book on the bookshelf next to
me that seems to me like it'll be an
amazingly good book as a textbook for a
course in a Physics course on complex
systems it's by Stefan thurner and
collaborators called introduction to the
theory of complex systems from Oxford
University press so I have an aspiration
of someday teaching a course on the
theory of complex systems which is
something that I only know a little bit
about so if that ever happens I will
certainly go through this book and try
to do exercises in it but I haven't done
that yet so that's why it's not a great
example
Eric stronquist says on the question of
probability in the ever interpretation
the leading ideas from you and siebens
from Wallace earlier Deutsch all
successfully explain why the born rule
should work but they don't explain the
mechanism how is it that the great
majority of or the greatest measure of
Observer moments with their memories of
a series of measurement results end up
distributed in the wave function so that
an observer chosen at random has usually
observed just about the right Quantum
statistics
so I I kind of want to unask this
question I don't buy the presumption of
the question the the
um the the underlying philosophy of it
um I mean it's cheating when you say and
let me read it again how is it the great
majority of Observer moments
um end up Distributing the wave function
so that an observer chosen at random has
usually observed just about the right
Quantum statistics that completely begs
the question what do you mean by chosen
at random uh in in many worlds there's
gonna be many different observers and
the whole question is what do you mean
by choosing it random
the thing about many worlds is like
let's not over complicate this it is
Crystal 100 super duper clear that if
you think that the theory implies any
probability rule at all that probability
rule is going to be the born rule there
was never any chance it was going to be
the probability is like equal to the
wave function or the wave function to
the fourth power or whatever it's just
Pythagoras's Theorem the hypotenuse
squared is the sum of the squares of the
sides that's where the born rule comes
from the right thing to do is to justify
why there is a probability measure at
all and I think that that's what chip
Stevens and I did we told you why there
is a probability measure and why it acts
like the born rule because there is
self-locating uncertainty so I don't
think there's anything more to be done
in in the cause of explaining the
mechanism I think we did explain the
mechanism self-locating uncertainty when
the wave function branches that's the
mechanism I suspect that
um your thought that we haven't
explained the mechanism them is a relic
of the thought that if if you have
probabilities they have to reduce at
some point to literally Counting
counting a certain fraction of things if
you think that there's a 30 chance that
X and a 70 chance that why then
somewhere in some abstract space there
are 30 y's and 70 X's or something like
that that's just not how many worlds
works and so I I don't I don't feel that
need to to satisfy that itch in order to
say that I have a mechanism I think I
know exactly what the mechanism is
Andrew Goldstein says I read things like
the October 30th Washington Post
editorial which tried to provide some
insight into the volatile activity of
the stock market and the fortunes of the
mega wealthy it leaves me even more
confused therefore I wonder whether you
see any potential for more sophisticated
understanding that would give us better
knowledge how to forecast the complex
social behaviors and interactions
observed in humans but poorly understood
well you know
sure I mean I I do see the potential for
that in the sense that I believe there
is a potential if I knew how to do it I
could be much more specific but I don't
okay there was interestingly very
recently something I I tweeted about
um a post on the blog marginal
Revolution which is shared by Tyler
Cowan previous mindscape guest but his
co-author
um Alex tarabak was the one who posted
it who was pointing to a new paper by
McDonald and shaleezie I believe it's
them which basically took some of the
most
commonly accepted economic models
DS d s g e I'm gonna get it wrong
Dynamic General system equilibrium some
combination of those words
um these models that everyone uses in
economics are very very popular
and roughly speaking it is only a slight
exaggeration to say that they said they
are completely nonsense
and here is how they show that they are
nonsense they used the model so what the
model means is there's certain
parameters right certain parameters for
different economic things this thing's
producing this there's a certain
volatility over here Etc and you can
change the parameters and get different
predictions for economic output GDP
unemployment whatever you want to get
okay so parameters leading to
predictions from these models so
basically they but this there's also
Randomness in them so you don't predict
deterministically because there's you
predict a probability distribution so
they use the model to make a prediction
to sort of predict a future history
given some parameters and then they took
that history and they fed it back into
the model and ask okay what are the
values of the parameters and there was
essentially no relationship between the
values of the parameters that they
derived and the ones they had put in in
fact they said you could even like
change the labels on the variables so
what they called the inflation rate they
they took the actual values of the
inflation rate and switched them for the
values of the unemployment rate and the
model found just as good a fit even
though that makes no sense whatsoever
I don't I haven't read this paper so I
don't know whether they're right or they
make some assumptions or they make some
mistakes I mean they're good people
um but it speaks to the difficulty of
modeling and forecasting these complex
social behaviors
so I guess what I'm saying is yes I
think we can do better but we're not
doing very well right now and
that's okay it's completely okay did not
do very well right now we're young and
not very uh good at this yet but we're
learning we're learning about the whole
idea of something called a complex
system there are some regularities in
complex systems even if they're only
statistical so I I remain optimistic
that we can do better but it's hard and
it's going to take a long time
Jim Murphy says I've developed a hobby
of creating cellular automata and
watching the emerging results of various
rules this is a good hobby I wish more
people had Hobbies like this
what do you need to do Jim by the way is
convert it into a social hobby right
like somehow make a website that
crowdsources cellular automata and and
see who's best at finding out the rules
anyway the question is the vast majority
of the rules seem to produce a chaotic
static without any I think it's a typo
here a chaotic situation without any
obvious complexity merging however I
wonder how much this is a result of my
limited computational power and World
size versus the inherent properties of
of the automata do you have any
intuition for how often rules that
appear chaotic at a small scale will
create immersion complexity on a larger
scale
um I have intuition but I don't know
whether my intuition is very good here I
do think the question is super duper
interesting so for those of you who
don't know
in The Game of Life for example
this was invented by the mathematician
John Conway famous you know checkerboard
kind of setup and you put some squares
down and then let them evolve according
to certain rules and you can see
patterns you can see things that look
like gliders and you can even see things
that are what are called glider guns
they're like a fixed configuration that
will spit out a series of gliders that
move away and you can even show that you
can do calculations using this whole
kind of setup similarly Stephen Wolfram
former mindscape guest I keep need to
say needing to say
um was able to show that you could do
similar things with one-dimensional
cellular automata rather than
two-dimensional ones so there are these
examples of emergence now maybe Jim you
should actually look at
um wolfram's Book on a new kind of
science because he's kind of interested
in this question in the in the world of
very very simple one-dimensional
cellular automata as long as you have
the idea that three sites at one time
step predict the one site below them at
the next time step you can literally
write down every possible rule okay and
then you can literally say here are
here's the subset of rules that lead to
emergent Behavior so you can count uh
but what you're asking is how does that
scale with more Dimensions more
complexity Etc I my intuition is that
even as things get bigger and higher
computational power it will still be
generically not true that you see simple
emergent Behavior I think that most
things will just be a chaotic mess
um
depending on what you allow yourself to
put in so for our world for our real
world Universe
um we certainly have emergent behavior
in the world you and I are examples of
emergent features immersion systems
um but that relies kind of heavily on
two things number one there is a
hierarchy of scales
so there are atoms that are made of
different masses there are particles are
made of different masses and crucially
there are photons which have no mass at
all so what this means is that the atoms
and the electrons and so forth bumping
into each other can dissipate by giving
off photons and so they're it's not very
easy to model that in a cellular
automaton because you're keeping track
of everything right and that it what an
astrophysicists do when they want to
think about you know the formation of a
star you don't keep track of every
Photon right the the sun is the star is
giving off heat or whatever and that's
dissipation and that sort of brings you
down into a Subspace of all the possible
configurations and gives you a handle on
what's going on and helps explain
emergent phenomena so that's one thing
the hierarchy of scales the other thing
is of course the past hypothesis the
fact that we begin in a very very very
special initial State and that allowed
complexity to arise as I've talked about
before along the way and as I talk about
in the big picture
um so
without those two very special features
I think that generically you would not
expect simple coherent large-scale
structures but this is again something
I'm totally happy to be wrong about
because I don't know of any
systematic exploration of the space of
possibilities there
okay the final question was a long one
terrible turnip not the question the AMA
has been long uh so Tara but I like it I
like doing these amas if I had more time
I would do them more I do not have more
time I don't even have time to do this
but I'm glad I'm doing it terrible
turnip says what is your view on how
specific a fundamental Theory should be
to feel right it seems there is a
paradox of sorts if one finds a theory
such that there is only one viable
self-consistent possibility that would
seem very strange on the other hand if
there are a huge range of possibilities
that would seem to make people
uncomfortable in that case you would end
up using anthropic principle type
arguments to justify one's observation
of this particular universe
you know I don't think that it's a
matter of feeling right in this sense I
mean some theories there is there is
something called feeling right I get
that you're you're on the right track
there
um
but the feeling right has to do more
with how simple and elegant the theory
is the ways in which you either directly
or indirectly connected with
observations the scope and fruitfulness
of the theory the compatibility of the
theory with other existing ideas that we
think are true things like that that's
what goes into making a theory feel
right you're focusing in on a very
important idea which is how
accepting or not accepting the theory is
of different kinds of solutions right if
there's we were talking about solving
equations if you have a set of equations
where there's only one solution versus
if you have a set of equations that have
many many solutions and both are
perfectly plausible
um I don't think that you should really
judge the feel of theories along that
particular Dimension
um
if I I can't imagine a theory that only
had one solution and also fit the data
but if you had it if you had a theory
that only had one solution and it was a
perfectly good fit to the universe I
think people would be ecstatic about
that the fact that it can't fit other
things that didn't happen should not
count as a strike against it is what I
would say on the other hand like you say
when there are a huge range of
possibilities you feel like it's almost
a shame you know someone like David
Gross the famous string theorist is very
upfront about the fact that throughout
his life he has been hoping to find the
one theory that uniquely predicted our
world that's why he's very sad at the
current
um popularity of more anthropic
explanations I don't quite feel that way
like I'm perfectly happy if the
fundamental theory predicts a whole
bunch of things and we're just a
statistical prediction within it maybe
it would have been nicer to be more
specific but you know I always always
say that we don't get to make demands of
the universe and how it operates I want
to figure out how the universe operates
I don't want to tell it how to operate
the very very good news is that the
Universe operates in such a way
seemingly that we can figure it out and
that's a non-trivial fact about the
universe
with respect to Jim's question on the
previous one if the laws of physics have
been different maybe we would had no
hope of figuring it out but not only can
we figure out something about the laws
of the universe but we can do it
piecemeal we can get better and better
at it we can get you know one regime
under control and then get more and more
and that's just the best way that's like
the most
um fruitful way to figure out these very
very deep very very wide-ranging
principles that make the universe run so
in all ways I would say count our
blessings that the universe is so nice
to us to help us figure it out and don't
tell the universe what to do would be my
advice all right thanks everyone for
hanging in there for the AMA
um happy beginning of fall like it's
fall here in Baltimore I it's been a
long time since I lived in the Northeast
I lived in a region of the country where
they didn't really have seasons in any
noticeable way so it's very very nice to
see the beautiful colors of the trees
and all that and don't don't uh imagine
that I don't know that the niceness will
not last forever because that's it's
coming there's going to be Winters
already gets dark very early around here
so um happy November happy Halloween if
I guess Halloween's already passed Happy
Thanksgiving Happy all the various
holidays that happened between December
and January talk to you soon
[Music]
thank you
[Music]